that stuff came out and it killed it it
crushed him right so
i lost the seat on a special election by
a guy who you know
the cop hater the fact right i mean the
guy can't run for dog catcher and hooks
anymore he's done because as soon as it
comes out he knows that
so now he leans into this you know
liberty
so you know he he's a the editor and
publisher and he writes a book and stuff
which is fine i mean you know i give him
credit you know
but um
you can't talk to guys like this because
they're so biased that you're not going
to be able to reach the people that are
going to put you over the top but
anyways he's quite a talker oh yeah she
loves it
i mean
he talks fast and he speaks well yeah he
does you know he's articulate
but i mean ultimately the people vote
for policy
not always but i mean you know when it
how are you nice to meet you
we'll caucus uh a couple of times before
[Music]
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
i thank you i want to take a moment of
silence there on behalf of those
veterans that made the ultimate
sacrifice to those that are serving in
okay thank you
i'm going to open up the hearing here on
i had the bill right here let me see
where i moved it
i didn't take any of your bills okay i
yeah see if he's outside
there i don't know
oh
53 16. i'll introduce it if he's not
here
and then what i'll do is i'll pass this
uh christopher arnold uh if you want can
you fill out you're gonna speak right
okay yes i got it here
i'm going to turn her over to
representative moffitt the chair of the
committee
okay the hearing is open at this time
for house bill
1653 relative to educational employment
opportunities and protections from
military families and their dependents a
point of personal privilege just a
moment before we go to the first speaker
we had a moment of silence earlier today
as is the chair's custom in this
committee and i did i just want to
mention i noticed the obituary today for
renee gagnon jr and as some of you know
randy gagnon senior
of new hampshire as one of the iwo jima
flag raisers
in
in 1945 in that it was in their famous
photo that was his dad rene gagne
gardens senior of new hampshire
so at this time the chair would like to
recognize representative
el balducero who's going to
introduce
sixteen fifty three
thank you mr chair for the record
representative al baldus our rockingham
county district five which is
londonderry
um
i'm in support hb 1653 iron co-sponsored
on the bill
and the reason why is because new
hampshire has a long standing history
of
making sure we have a school compact
okay for veterans here throughout the
country any veterans coming in
uh to the state of new hampshire where
they
kids can step in
and if they aren't playing sports and
there's baseball football everything's
already up and the running they're able
to get on the team uh without any any
denials
um it's the same thing with the
licenseer
and credentialing i actually sponsored
that about for spouses and military
anyone coming into new hampshire
will automatically be um
go to the licensing and they'll work
with them there they get their licensing
or credentialing so we can get them
right to work
it's the same thing on the yellow ribbon
build and the ones i'm bringing up a dod
recommendations
okay uh they have what they call a 10 10
point list i think it's called something
like that
and i've been working with the dod for
many years on this stuff here so we're
all on the same sheet of music around
the country
the
other bill that we we did that works
hand in hand with this one is that if a
veteran
moves into the state of new hampshire
he's going to use his yellow ribbon gi
bill
then he would automatically as soon as
he got apartment he would automatically
get in-state tuition
and we were fortunate to get that passed
there
but this bill we have here
from department of defense which is
christopher arnold who will break this
down a little bit farther
on the bill you all should have got a
letter in the emails from christopher
arnold the department of defense on this
i mean this works hand in hand i'm
trying to think on the section here um
you know basically on best practices
expressing the department's fullest
intent for you know a number of the key
issues affecting service members
we have many service members that move
in and out of new hampshire
whether it be from recruiting all
branches or the reserve centers the
active force that runs the reserve
centers or the reserve component or our
national guard or here national guard
that were you know
and especially with the new aircraft
that pease air force base got you know
brought i'm sure it brought in a lot of
uh veterans into the state
so this is a win-win for the community
and uh we're definitely uh we should you
know support it a hundred percent
and if you have any questions i'm gonna
leave those for christopher arnold
okay on this bill
and uh that way there you'll get it
straight from the department of defense
so we don't do anything repetitious here
okay
is i hear that uh you're going to defer
questions to subsequent speakers of
thank you representative thank you
before we get to uh
the aforementioned christopher arnold we
have uh
representative doug thomas is in the
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
committee for uh having me here i just
uh
doug thomas of the record londonderry
rockingham five i very quick full
support of the spill as a retired air
force and
i fully well understand
what the what our veterans go through
and this bill just is a continuation of
uh showing that we just can't do enough
for our veterans so all i'm going to say
is i'm in full support of the bill
veterans deserve this their dependence
to
deserve this and
that's all i wanted to say i want to go
on on a record as supporting this bill
any questions again defer to the people
behind me thank you
thank you representative
no
all right as has been advertised uh
chris arnold
uh not representative but uh
from dod
is in the house mr arnold
good morning chairman honorable
committee members
the department of defense is grateful
for the opportunity to support the
policies reflected in house bill 1653 i
am christopher arnold the northeast
region liaison at the united states
department of defense state liaison
office operating under the direction of
the under secretary of defense for
personnel and readiness i am a us army
combat veteran of operation iraqi
freedom two and three as brevity is the
soul of wit i will endeavor not to
repeat much of what my written testimony
has already said about the department's
continuum for license reciprocity the
status of licensed portability in new
hampshire and federal statute which
includes licensure as part of the
military service's strategic basing
criteria our bottom line is a license
within 30 days taking care of military
families is the fourth line of effort in
the united states national defense
strategy pre-pandemic research showed
that unemployment rates for licensed
military spouses were as high as 28
percent
since 2017 the department has
established and is working on three
lines of effort to improve license
portability for military spouses these
lines of efforts seek to immediately
improve state licensing laws to allow a
military spouse to receive a license
with minimal initial paperwork within 30
days of their application
in the near term to ensure that state
licensing boards implement their laws
and make information about their
application practices accessible to
military spouses and long term to
approve profession-specific licensure
compacts which the department perceives
as the optimum end-state solution to
portability an area where new hampshire
and this committee has been an
unquestionable leader nationwide as
there is not currently a compact for
every occupation nor is every state a
member of each compact the department
continues to engage the states on the
issue of military spousal licensure and
pursue a variety of approaches to
reciprocity simultaneously while the
states continue to work towards better
portability the best evidence we have
about the quality benefits of licensure
relate to occupations that are
universally licensed which tend to have
more harmonized standards across states
where we do not have any strong evidence
however is to suggest that the type of
license recognition in house bill 1653
is associated with worse quality or
worse care outcomes providing a
temporary license to qualified
applicants who have proven competency in
another state allows the military spouse
to practice while fulfilling
requirements needed to qualify for
endorsement in new hampshire
or awaiting verification of
documentation supporting an endorsement
or a background check
this type of well-designed licensure
regime can enhance public safety while
expanding health care access in
historically underserved communities and
participation in the workforce by
historically excluded groups such as
military spouses thanks to the
leadership of both the new hampshire
general court and the new hampshire
department of military affairs and
veteran services the department of
defense has enjoyed a close ongoing
working relationship with the new
hampshire office of professional life
insurance certification who is in
support of this bill to improve
implementation of existing statutes new
hampshire's cultural norm to ask the
question if individuals or their
families have served in the military has
led to the inclusion of a means to
indicate military spouse status on all
license applications the department of
defense is now asking state policy
makers to assess the actions of the
licensing boards to implement these
changes to laws and make information
about licensure more easily acceptable
research by dod's office of people
analytics has found an empirical link
between spousal support for a service
member to stay on active duty and actual
retention outcomes the policies
contained in this legislation also serve
in support of new hampshire's current
and future military connected students
their parents and new hampshire's
education ecosystem that serves them
military connected children will benefit
when educators in schools create a
culture which facilitates their unique
educational requirements and needs house
bill 1653 supports the emotional and
academic needs of children in the
national guard and reserve component
families by specifying school districts
make certain resources available to
reserve component children when their
parent is mobilized this creates an
opportunity for military impacted
schools to bridge the gap between
educators and evaluators of granular
k-12 metrics utilized in basing
decisions by the military services such
as the department of the air force
this legislation provides further help
by waiving proof of residency
requirements until the
military-connected students who arrive
in new hampshire on military transfer
orders
are physically present in the state
providing military families with
increased flexibility through access to
district open enrollment policies and
guaranteeing in-state tuition continuity
for military-connected students who have
been accepted but not yet enrolled into
the university of new hampshire system
and the new hampshire community college
system even if the sponsor has a
permanent change of station prior to
attending class
these policies mitigate issues that
cannot be addressed by new hampshire's
military interstate children's compact
commission while also promoting
consistency for all military children
transferring into and out of school
systems throughout the nation
finally house bill 1653 affirms and
safeguards re-employment rights for
national guard and reserve component
service members
in new hampshire serving in other states
the labor market is more competitive
than ever last year just over the border
in the pine tree state the governor
signed a bill which contained an almost
identical proposal and the provisions
for enrollment timing and protecting
intuition
the massachusetts state senate has
passed almost the same bill they call it
the spouse license portability education
and enrollment of dependence or speed
act in fact 29 states have enacted
policies for licensure enhancement 35
states have addressed licensure access
32 states have allowed for advanced
enrollment four states have already
passed school placement equity equity
which is our newest issue for 2022. 35
states have addressed in-state tuition
continuity and 46 states have passed
state employment protections for the
national guard while this is promising i
can think of no single state which has
addressed all these policies together
as house bill 1653 would do passage of
these policies would make new hampshire
the unquestioned leader nationwide in
addressing key quality of life issues
for uniformed service members and their
families we are particularly grateful to
you uh chairman for all of your past
leadership on this committee all of your
efforts working hand-in-hand with the
department of defense uh for your
service to our country as well as to the
bill sponsor representative roy for his
service as well as always as liaison to
the northeast i stand ready to answer
whatever questions you may have thank
you
thank you very much
questions for
he's better looking than i am so
i
i do want to ask uh
chris if uh
reciprocity so i see the new language
would allow someone who served in a
another state's
militia or national guard
they even if they didn't serve in this
state if they were residents of this
state then they would be eligible for
the for the benefit is that correct
correct so uh you likely have uh
instances for example where folks might
be assigned to a
naval shipyard portsmouth and they are
residents of new hampshire
if they're called to active military
service uh in maine uh they would not be
eligible for state employment
protections under the state uh service
members civil relief act uh because
ucera does not
pertain to title 32 national guard and
reserve component service similarly if
you're a new hampshire resident and
you're serving in the massachusetts
national guard or you work in new
hampshire and your job is is in the
state of new hampshire but you're
serving in the vermont national guard
you do not get those employment
protections if the governor of vermont
calls you to active duty
so the reciprocity
really is not
in effect across the board some states
may similarly
honor
a new hampshire
national guardsmen who served in the new
hampshire guard but they now live in a
different state
that may or may not they may or may not
be able to access the same benefit in
another state depends on the state is
that roger so 46 states have
passed this provision and new hampshire
pennsylvania
uh new york and maryland are the four
remaining uh to add the language this
state or any other state to their
statute so we're one of four states that
needs that is not in sync with the other
46 that's what i'm hearing correct okay
uh questions other questions
uh is that representative oregon did you
have a hand up
thank you much
very much mr chair um you mentioned
the portraits naval shipyard or as you
put in naval shipyard portsmouth um is
that considered to be in maine or new
hampshire for the purpose of this bill
roger so the the physical location of
the shipyard uh is in in maine i know
that's controversial but uh neighbor
navy operation center manchester
provides uh federal housing for the
shipyard just uh just over the border
uh from kittery in in actual portsmouth
new hampshire so there are federal
uh components of the shipyard on both
sides of the border and true okay thanks
uh representative baldicero
yeah i'm not i'm not going to ask any
questions about the bill but i want to
your your uh speech that you gave uh
your testimony can you send us a copy of
that roger you're happy
yeah send it to me and then i'll share
with representative loomis for the
record roger okay thank you
other questions for uh
yes
thank you for taking my time
i just have a question about reciprocity
of licensing and i am a licensed new
hampshire licensed psychologist so i
understand these problems in moving
across states so if someone comes here
for example with a psychologist's
license and i know
there are a lot of psychologists in the
military
automatically be issued a license by the
new hampshire state board or how would
that work i'm just copy so
under federal law
uh if you're serving uh uh
on federal active duty a valid license
in any state is all that's required so
if a person is is assigned to any of the
uniformed services whether that's the
united states public health service the
army the navy the air force and they're
assigned to new hampshire they would
operate under their
state home state license and they don't
need a specific fix
where
where the department of defense has
identified
uh the the challenge insofar as
retention outcomes is for spousal
support so it's when they're moving
across the country and let's say their
spouse is a licensed uh clinical
psychologist and as you likely know the
psychology inter-jurisdictional compact
isn't a true uh uh privilege to practice
as the other compacts are it's more of a
telehealth a 30-day privilege
type of mechanism so that is why having
a good
state specific
licensing law that would allow a spouse
to
pursue the full state license but still
operate when they're coming from a
non-compact state so for example if
they're coming from massachusetts which
has not yet joined
scipac and they're re-assigned from
hanscom air force base
let's say to new boston space force
station
uh that spouse would be eligible for a
license under
this provision if they meet certain
requirements such as holding a valid out
of state license for a certain period of
time and they're issued the temporary
license and
have i think one chance to renew it
while they're pursuing whatever state
specific requirements there are to
other questions
yeah
representative gallagher um
so
um yeah i'm i i'm kind of curious more
about the
um
licensing
reform aspect about it um which yeah you
did a good job explaining so far um
a
issue area that
i've been noticing increased activism
surrounding lately so i was kind of
wondering if you could
fit
um
fit the pro licensing provisions
in this bill into
the larger
occupational licensing
conversation
like letting us know what
groups and literature on the topic
you've consulted
copy so the
the issue of military spouse licensure
has been a concern of the department um
for
really over a decade now
and in my written testimony which i
apologize if you haven't received a copy
but
you know i go into a fair amount of
detail so
the original ask
between
2011 and 2016
by the department of defense to the
states was to approve
profession specific
uh intra-state licensure laws uh for a
number of pathways towards a full
license whether that was licensed by
endorsement
uh whether that was an expedited license
or whether that was a reciprocal license
and
what we found over time was the
definition of reciprocity or the
definition of expedited varied from
state to state and every state likes to
think they have expedited uh licensure
but there's a difference between you
know putting something at the top of the
pile and then taking eight months to
adjudicate that pile or getting the
license uh out the door
in ten days so
uh we uh engaged with the clearinghouse
for a military family readiness at
pennsylvania state university uh in 2021
and they did an exhaustive 50-state
review of six occupational boards in
each state with real military spouses
going on the website looking for the
information calling up and seeing if the
person that they were speaking to
uh was knowledgeable and trained
actually filling out the application to
test how long it took and that was a
follow-on study to the 2017 effort
by the center for military reach at
university of minnesota we also have an
annual congressional reporting
requirement
to the house armed services committee
pursuant to the national defense
authorization act so each year
we update the congress on the status of
removing barriers to military spousal
licensure within each state so
to your question specifically this
particular approach we're sort of the
carrot if you will we can show you best
practices from other states but we don't
have a a real box that we want you to go
in other than to get that license out
the door within 30 days
and for a temporary licensure regardless
of the military spouse's years of
experience in an occupation boards often
look to test scores and academic records
which can take a tremendous amount of
time to verify if they're asking for
your
college algebra from 1996. um military
assignments have a duration of
approximately two to three years so most
folks will be on their fifth or sixth uh
license and uh depending on the state
may have to hold
those licenses in another state in order
to receive reciprocity and it can be
expensive to maintain you know four or
five licenses to get to one license in
another state because i need the the
one type of training from this state and
another type of training for that state
and i've amalgamated a license myself so
military spouses who have maintained a
successful career in a variety of
locations and circumstances expressed
frustration over having to justify their
credibility and competency in the same
manner as first-time applicants
which is why i think this bill would
provide a pathway
to get them to working just a little bit
faster while they're pursuing whatever
new hampshire
specific safeguards there are in place
to obtain that full state license
because that's always going to be their
goal
and with the population of military
spouses about 5 000 probably less than
half in licensed occupations
and many of them would already qualify
under a compact uh or because they have
an out-of-state license for a full
license you're talking about you know a
few dozen people a year so it's sort of
a de minimis uh impact
in in the whole but it's still a good
option to have in the toolkit in my
opinion
okay thank you
saying none thank you sir for being here
and um anything else would you like to
add thank you chairman honored to be
here and uh looking forward to uh
exploring the capitol uh after the
hearing so all right and thank you for
all right mr kevin grady is back in the
house or i should say the lob
from state veterans advisory committee
thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee uh
you heard a lot from me last week
fortunately we only have one hearing
this week um for you anyway uh i might
for the record my name is kevin grady i
represent the
the state veterans advisory committee i
am a 25-year air force veteran and a
23-year resident of hooksett new
hampshire the state veterans advisory
committee is is really happy to support
this bill
and every chance that i get to talk to
people
about veterans and things like that i
always like to try and leave them with
this thought
when one of us serves the whole family
serves and the military veterans in this
in this in this audience know what i'm
talking about in terms of the the
hardship that spouses and children go
through when you pick up and move every
couple of years and as i was thinking
about what i wanted to tell you today i
grew i not only had a military family of
my own but i grew up in a military
family my father was in the air force
and as i sat down last night i thought
to myself you went to a lot of different
schools
um from grade 1 to grade 12 i went to 10
different schools
and and you know while that's a pretty
large number i don't think that seven or
eight schools to get 12 years in is that
uncommon across our military and so
it's a little easier for today's kids
because they've got cell phones and they
can face time with their friends at the
old place while they're making new
friends at the at the new location but
anything we can do to help those people
make that transition better
i i'm really in favor of so i was very
excited to see
us talking about
special services for kids it it's it's a
little bit rare for someone to get
transferred in the middle of the year it
generally speaking most military moves
have sort of migrated to the summer time
to make this process a little easier but
things like command slots and things
like that might require that you that
you transition in january
and you might know that two or three
months ahead of time and if you have the
opportunity to enroll your kids in
school already and perhaps at that
school level those teachers could reach
out to your children electronically
we're doing a lot of stuff
electronically now as it is if you could
reach out to those kids electronically
and say here's what we're doing in our
eighth grade math class right now so you
know here's the things you ought to be
trying to look and here's some
assignments that you can do and i'll
grade them and then that way you can get
a grade for these things as you as you
move on so i'm really excited about that
and the idea that if if somebody's going
to be deployed there could be some
access to some special services that are
called for in this bill for a young
child particularly if you think about it
what about a single parent that gets
deployed no they've got to have a plan
for what they're going to do with their
their children but that could be a
fairly traumatic experience and the
folks at the school ought to know about
that and be ready to go with a with a
plan to help out kids if they start to
see a a drop off in their performance or
or signs that they're that things are
not right
with them
before we made the transition over at
peace to the kc-46 tanker we had
actually stood up an active duty kc 135
squadron right alongside of our our
guard unit and as i told you the other
day the crews are interchangeable can do
all this stuff i would expect as the
kc-46 really fully comes on board with
this refueling capabilities we're going
to do the same thing we're going to be
looking at probably about 100
or so military families over at uh at
pease when all this is said and done
that are active duty and that are going
to rotate in and out the temporary
licensing thing
the most important part of that is it
allows that spouse to work immediately
okay while they're working through any
specific thing that they don't have in
their profile that they need to get
licensed in new hampshire it allows them
to get a job right now because as
anybody in here who has ever moved knows
moving is expensive
and you don't get reimbursed all the
time for everything you that you do and
if that if you've been relying on that
spouse's money to to make ends meet it's
important to have that opportunity for
that spouse especially in a professional
field to get hired
right away
the in-state tuition thing i noted in
the financial note that the community
college system says it's probably going
to be transparent to them the university
system didn't think that there would be
much impact there but i'll leave you
with this thought if if a student starts
their education at the university of new
hampshire
and particularly if you know now active
duty folks can transfer their gi bill
eligibility to their children if they
want to and so now their children are
going to school on the gi bill you've
got gi bill benefit money coming to the
state of new hampshire if if we don't
sweeten the pot by saying you can
continue the in-state to win tuition
in new hampshire if your family moves
out of state you can just stay and be a
full-time student at unh then the
possibility exists that we may lose
revenue on this deal because that that
family will say well it's going to be
more less expensive for us to put our
child in a college in the new location
and it's not fair to the student who
really maybe is loving where they are
and now through no fault of their own
they're going to have to move yet again
um i want to leave you with the thought
that when i translated to transf uh when
i
i spoke on house bill 1505 which which
was the military justice contract last
time and i said the more that as federal
programs work their way down the state
level the more we can be sort of
mirroring those things the better off
we're going to be i just kind of want to
remind you of that and also
hb 1056 that we talked about last week
that you folks put on the on the consent
calendar as ought to pass with the idea
of
studying how we attract veterans to the
state putting a committee together to
work specifically on that this bill i
think goes a long way to to fulfilling
those goals and that's really all i want
to talk about this morning unless you
have any questions
representative gallagher
um yeah sorry just as a substitute on
this committee i didn't uh quite catch
your name could you repeat that my name
is kevin grady g-r-a-d-y and i represent
the state veterans advisory committee
we're chartered by state rsa to
we have 20 member organizations and
we're chartered by state rsa to come and
speak for the veteran population in new
hampshire
okay thanks yes sir
okay mr gray would you believe that i
really
uh appreciate the
the measure that was changed a few years
ago allowing
veterans to transfer their educational
benefits to their children
and would you believe that i was able to
actually personally uh take advantage of
that
change
and would you believe that i had a
daughter who went to college before that
was in effect and she graduated with
a
great debt and my subsequent daughter
had everything paid for because of this
veteran's benefit transfer benefit and
finally would you believe that
one daughter is very happy with me and
one is not because of that so yes sir i
can
i can certainly appreciate that the
person that has no debt is is feeling a
lot better about life uh yeah thank you
that and that's uh something where i
have to work through internally yeah
other other other questions
thank you so much mr grady german anyone
if not i will declare this
here in close and i will return the
gavel to
our chair
thank you uh
representative moffat i got a question
uh since we're off the record now for
christopher uh
years ago we passed the education bill
on
veterans moving into the state because
the yellow ribbon program only paid
in-state tuition
did they ever fix that bill where
veterans go anywhere in the country
and pay in-state or is it still an
i believe that came off of our key issue
list in or around
2009 or 2010 because the congress did
ultimately provide a 50-state solution
in the ndia okay thank you is howard
cooney still working for the dod uh
negative he retired after 50 years of
service and he he suckered me into
taking uh his job
for those that i know on the committee
here that have been here long enough
harold cooney was the dod rep here that
we worked for years new hampshire about
six years ago i believe i think it was
six years we were the first state in the
country really to put in licensing and
credentialing so i was honored to be
invited by michelle obama to go to the
white house and sit at the table because
she was pushing licensing and
credentialing throughout the whole
country
and we had a meeting i was only state
rep at the table at the white house with
all the union members sitting around
there and discussing
licensing and what we did in new
hampshire so i was honored basically to
go and do that on behalf of the state of
new hampshire but howard cooney was a
great
great guy there for the state and helped
us tremendously here on veterans issues
roger and uh
harold is still involved he's the
chairman of the
legislative affairs committee at the
military officers association of america
so uh for any moa members or any uh you
know persons interested uh in joining uh
harold is uh is still helping from the
sidelines that's awesome well you give
them tom nice to get my best please
roger we'll do all right thanks
okay
um
what we're going to do we're going to be
executing hopefully about uh 10
and um
what i want to do is uh you will be
caucusing
okay uh i recommend you knock caucus
we're gonna go upstairs and the reason
why we're gonna uh knock caucus here
because this is on youtube
so i recommend the uh for the democrats
you go to another area
okay and then we're gonna go up on the
third deck and then we'll meet back down
here about 10 o'clock
and then we will start executing now
we've already we've been fortunate
because as we
uh stuck together as a whole team
republican democrats and we uh one two
three four five
we've already um knocked out six of our
uh 19 bills
so hopefully uh we'll be able to move
quick
and then this committee work will be
done until we do crossover whatever
comes over from the senate
okay so therefore let's go ahead and
take a break upstairs for the
republicans on the third floor if you
get off the elevator you take a right
it's that first door
uh where we have that room there i don't
know i think it's 301 i'm not sure
3018. so we'll meet you all up there
thank you
thank you uh
we're going to uh start executive
session here we all sit on the left and
the right we have our numbers we're
ready to sit
thank you
okay
what i'm going to do i'm going to start
off with the uh bill that we just had so
we don't have to keep the department of
defense hanging out here with us
but anyways under um i'm going to open
up the executive session on hb
1653.
and i will make a motion there to ought
to pass
okay
okay and i'll speak to the motion if
pretty simple uh you know we've been
passing legislation like this for a long
time and this one here is the next step
uh above on making sure we're taking
care of our own whether it be to
licensing
um
you know credentialing is taking care of
spouses
um you know on equal rights on education
opportunity for veterans here in the
state so this is pretty much a win-win i
don't think i need to beat this anymore
i thought
arnold did a great presentation there on
the legislation
so are there any questions or concerns
seeing none i'm going to ask the um
clerk to take a roll call okay
uh representative moffat
yes to otp
rollins yeah representative delemus yes
representative notter yes representative
foster yes representative
yes representative harley yes
representative levitt
representative massimila yes
representative pedro yeah
representative query
yes
representative jack yes representative
oregon
yes
excellent
21-nothing 21.
that's beautiful okay without any uh
objections uh we'll put this on the
okay now keep in mind on any one of
these bills here you know some could get
pulled off the calendar hopefully tim
horrigan will maintain and be on good
behavior they won't pull any off okay uh
no just kidding
but anyways uh
yeah i'll do the blurb on that there uh
the the report
so um
but if you if for some reason any of
these bills come off uh be prepared i'm
gonna need
you know maybe uh i'll be setting up
who's to speak and who's going to do the
pi
or if you're going to challenge any
bills then please let me know
if you're going to do the pi or who's
going to speak either courtesy thank you
okay the next bill will be house
resolution 16. representative mass
you got that oh
and would you like to speak to your uh
sure
um
house bill 16
hr16
deals with the nuclear waste issue and
because we do have a nuclear waste plant
here in new hampshire i think it is
pertinent
and relevant so i recommend ought to
pass
okay is there anyone else who wants to
speak to this ought to pass motion
representative branch uh i know i'm the
prime sponsor and it seems like a
conflict of interest to say anything but
this is just a common sense resolution
to say
we don't want nuclear waste in our
backyard we want a permanent solution
for nuclear waste we don't want it to be
sitting at seabrook nuclear power plant
forever we want a permanent solution
that is away from us away from anybody
it could be anywhere else but in our
okay we have a motion on the floor uh
ought to pass on house resolution 16 and
i'll ask the clerk to take a roll call
vote
representative
yes to uh to pass
uh otp lundgren yes representative katz
chorus
representative rollins yeah
representative delanis yes
representative notter yes representative
foster representative
yes representative harley yes
representative levitt
representative massimila yes
representative piedra yes representative
oops
i'm sorry
representative query yes
sorry about that and uh representative
jack yes
let me make sure i write this stuff in
here
wilhelm yes representative jack that's
correct uh representative morgan yes
representative gallagher
yes representative
representative lebranch yes
yes representative yes and
representative
yes excellent 21.
uh house resolution 16 is uh 21-0 with
any objection we'll move that to the
consent calendar
okay uh and then of course keep in mind
i'm gonna need a um
we'll pass down a um
committee report hold on just a second i
have that right here and i don't have it
filled out so they'll have to
if they need that to be filled out you
see bill number is let me see
hr 16 16. yep
sorry about that i'm going to close on
h.r 16.
okay yeah i want to pass that to him
and it's on consent calendar so make
sure you check that consent box
okay
i'm gonna open up one sec you know h16
i'm going to open up the uh house uh to
the hr 15
and uh recognize representative moffat
for a motion
thank you mr i would like to move um
on
sorry i'm new to this mr chairman what's
that
i have an amendment uh i'm sorry i'm new
to this i don't know the process for an
amendment yeah that's fine uh can you
so motion's been made yeah we have an
ought to pass motion on the thing but
now we're going to go to the amendment
we going to the amendment
amendment
okay
are we all said we passing that
thanks
this house should forever copy the
resolution of the president
did you get it yet
okay it's coming around
okay what is it number
zero one three one
is there a second to the amendment uh
who second the amendment excuse me we
have a motion by uh
you're going to make a motion on this
amendment yep what's your amendment
what's your motion
to pass the amendment
we have a second
i'll second who's second bro okay we
oh boy hold on for you
for you and then the uh i'm gonna so i'm
going to go
this is this is numbered one sec we're
just playing catch up here
the branch so this is going to be
um amendment zero
okay we have an arthropass um
on amendment
two zero two two
dash zero one three h for hr15
do you want to
okay the floor is yours thank you mr
chair so uh this amendment is a slight
oversight i had when drafting uh it's a
house resolution condemning the
communist party of china and the
people's republic of china but i seem to
have forgotten to add the ambassador uh
of the people's republic of china to the
united states in the original bill so
this adds the ambassador of the republic
of china as one of the people who will
receive a copy of this house resolution
and it also adds the taiwanese
ambassador uh to the list of places that
this uh house resolution will be sent if
passed
okay uh is there anyone else who want to
speak
on
representative moffat
famous chairs have a question uh i know
we certainly have a
ambassador from the prc
uh
in that we don't have diplomatic formal
diplomatic relations with uh
the republic of china taiwan
i do if we don't have an if there is no
ambassador from
who i'm just trying to understand who
this would go to
uh
and um so you can find that at the last
line it's the taipei economic and
cultural representative because we
currently do not have formal relations
with the republic of china due to the
one china policy which i wholeheartedly
disagree with
we have a
an ambassador
but not called an ambassador it's called
the taiwanese uh representative office
and they're technically not in an
embassy but for all intents and purposes
they are
perfect got it thank you
okay
this was an amendment i thought it was
coming but
um
we didn't discuss this one anyway but i
agree
with you i do so yeah
okay
ah what's that can i speak oh yes
i just want to say that i am opposed to
this amendment i think that it's um
inappropriate for us as a committee and
the house to be a pining on
international affairs and this amendment
actually makes the bill worse by
communicating directly with a foreign
government
our diplomatic offices federally so i'm
okay anyone else uh representative chase
i i i wholeheartedly support the
amendment i think the reason why is it
makes sense the people in new hampshire
and people of america right now are very
upset with them the way that this regime
has treated other countries in the
region i think it makes perfect sense
that for this body to be able to voice
its opinion on the international stage
of how this regime has treated its own
people other people that it's
essentially colonized
and
and how it's treated even our country on
the international stage too i think i
think more states more countries the
united states as a whole needs to
wholeheartedly denounce this regime and
really stand up so if new hampshire is
one of the first states to send such a
strong statement why not
i think the people expect it i think i
think china really is a uh it's a demon
to democracy and um and freedom
around the world so i think this is a
great step in the right direction i
appreciate that representative lebranch
brought this forward i think it's also
good too for us to uh we're denouncing
them
we should you know we should say it to
their face
right why say it just in hollow words
and just send it to the congress for it
to be lost on the clerk's desk there
it should go right to their desk yup
thanks moffatt
famous chair i think representative
piedra makes a very valid legitimate uh
observation in that uh is that our our
job to make such a resolution and my
thought to that is that there is a long
history in this body of occasionally
discussing which we've done and voting
on which will do
resolutions on all manner of things so i
think that uh
representative pierre makes a very valid
point um
but i i also support the amendment and
uh and we'll discuss and vote on it as
is our our custom
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to take a
roll call vote on amendment uh hr 15
representative moffitt
yes on the amendment
representative kat zakoros yes
representative rollins
representative delanus yes
representative knotter
representative foster
representative deshay yes representative
harley
representative
no no
representative gallagher
no
representative
now
representative lebranch yes
representative lawton no
alkowitz no
hey
paul to seven i'm not sorry
representative
yes forgive me
again
to 11-10
okay
uh now i am looking uh representative
thank you mr i'll return to my original
motion uh only to change it from
otp recommendation to otpa
okay
we have a motion on octopass pass as
amendment i'll second that
um it's open for discussion
representative moffat
famous show we spoke at length
about this earlier and the uh
the opinion of apparently or at the time
we'll find out momentarily the majority
was that this is a message that was
worth sending with regard to the
behavior of the
prc people's republic of china
thank you is there anyone else who would
like to speak
representative matt miller
thank you
i'm against this because again this
i don't really feel this is the purview
of the committee can you speak into the
mike please because it's out of here i
am
can you hear me
everybody you can hear me right
better better okay
okay um as i was saying i don't think it
is the purview of the committee
to um you know get involved in
international policies and so that's why
i will vote against this bill thank you
nobody else okay with that i'm going to
ask the uh clerk to take a roll call
vote on ought to pass as amendment on
yes on otpa
representative lundgren no
representative ken segoros
representative rollins
representative delemus yes
representative notter yes representative
foster
representative deshay yes representative
no
yes
representative
no
me and representative
yes
okay um
representative moffitt be doing the
majority uh report and uh
who who's going to do the um
minority i'll do it i'll do it
that's the majority
what's that i'll do the minority okay
i'm gonna close the executive session on
hr15 and give us a few seconds to catch
keep in mind i'm going to need these
minority of uh majorities uh before we
leave today so i can get it all turned
in and right
um hr what 16 uh yeah that's consent yes
okay and then um
representative masamila are you doing
the minority yeah do you mind writing
the title in
oh hey it's gonna cost you all right i
got everything else going for you no
problem thank you
okay
okay we all set on that
i believe we are
okay
that was 15 yes yeah let me see let me
make sure i logged it in right here
that was a otp
slash a
11 nothing
and
vtt moffat okay on a second
okay
let's move on here to hr 7
i'm going to open up the executive
session on h.r 17. representative foster
yes thank you mr chairman
i would like to
make a motion
on
h.r 17 ought to pass
i have a motion on the uh
for ought to pass
second by uh
represent
no
okay well i'll second that for you then
how's that i'll help you get organized
thank you
all right
okay
yep second yeah
okay representative foster you want to
uh
speak to your past
so this resolution is basically saying
uh that we oppose the federal and state
efforts to establish a carbon tax on
fuels for electricity and transportation
and um
considering that we know there's a
an established
correlation between
the cost of energy and the availability
energy and the
um
the
standard of living for for people within
a society
and that currently we're looking at
record inflation
and um
that we're also looking at um
energy shortages rolling blackouts and
having um
the cost of fuels
the skyrocket i think that a a carbon
tax at this time would be detrimental to
our society and
and i'm encouraging people to vote um
ought to pass on this resolution
thank you uh is there anyone out
uh representative welkowitz
thank you mr chair for the opportunity
to speak out in strong opposition to
house resolution 17. i was born at 347
parts per million co2
and today we're at 417 parts per million
co2
this means peril for people who live in
new hampshire and across the planet
for my daughter's future for your
children's future for your
grandchildren's future i urge all to
stand up for what we stand on
i will vote no
on h.r 17. thank you
anyone else
representative nada thank you mr
chairman i'm a guest on this committee
uh so thank you for letting me you've
been on this committee a long time i
started out here first two terms and you
were my chairman
i respectfully disagree with my esteemed
colleague on the other side over there i
serve on the committee of science
technology and energy i have for four
terms now i attend conferences on energy
and energy related
things and i can tell you that new
hampshire has the lowest
output right now in the whole nation
it's
.0029 percent we're not in peril and you
cannot run the country on
the unreliables so
there's no teeth to this resolution it's
just a strong statement like enough is
enough
thank you well thank you representative
you're trying to say that we're going to
save his daughter we're already doing
pretty good
is that what you're saying
she has a fine father she'll be fine no
there we go we're all set all right
anyone else want to speak up uh
representative horgan
um yes so i oppose this resolution um
i think uh
the cost of emitting co2 in the
atmosphere i think they're real i
although i've not attended
i think the people who are speaking at
the conferences that the other
gentlelady just mentioned i think
they're just just plain wrong i i trust
the experts who say
that um the co2
levels
are causing uh
climate change in that climate changing
of catastrophic results especially if
you live near the seacoast like i do and
in fact it already is having those
results and
also
not a couple of the bullet points are
just plain false including the one about
uh
the tax code shouldn't be used to
manipulate consumer decisions there's
all kinds of incentives in the tax code
so that's uh
regardless of which party is
uh in charge or what their goals are so
that's uh you know changing the consumer
decisions is indeed one of the central
functions of the tax tax code
and
and also in addition to the co2 the
alternatives are
that would mostly cause a shift
renewable energy like solar wind power
and water power and
by the way the uh
if you worry about the fact that wind
doesn't blow all the time or there's
cloudies there are like various
divisions i can do
a new um
invention called the battery which may
be a few if you've ever heard of another
so that's um
anyways i would just say uh
i would just say that so i just say like
this this is a bad um
bad bill on its merits and also of
course sending an hr nobody really we're
gonna get a letter from the speaker's
office none of these
officials that we're sending things to
are gonna change their uh
the our congressional delegation is
probably not going to change their
opinion just based on this nicely
done up official letter from the speaker
so i
i would vote it a lot but anyway
i vote itl on this because i think uh
you know
it's it's the wrong it's the wrong
message and the wrong way to send it and
the wrong thing to do about it so thank
you
thank you uh representative branch
thank you mr chair uh
i am the youngest representative ever in
the new hampshire house uh i'm one of
these people that will be affected by
let them speak please
please let them
speak i'm just saying uh
actual record-wise i am the youngest
office holder of a new hampshire
representative i thought i was but go
ahead
so
so at age 20 i i have a long life ahead
of me i hope uh
and and i'm one of these people that
will be affected by climate change and
this is simply just putting a price on
pollution just like if you throw a water
bottle out your window you will be fine
for pollution we're putting carbon in
the atmosphere we're putting pollutants
into the air and it just seems like
common sense to be taxing pollution
because we already do so when it comes
to throwing your garbage on the side of
the road
and two
my esteemed colleague on the other side
talking about how unreliable renewables
are
i'm one of the few representatives that
is pro-nuclear energy
and i would say that nuclear energy is a
carbon neutral form of power and it will
serve as a base load so if we can have a
mix of renewables and nuclear power
and nuclear power as a base load that
will at least keep a consistent uh
rate of energy for when we have spikes
in demand during the daytime
thank you are there any other uh
representative nada
thank you and i disagree with my friend
over there and i am i'm happy to hear
that you're for nuclear energy because
and there's no carbon emissions at all
with nuclear energy it's a very fine um
form of energy
the carbon tax has not worked in europe
and u.s the u.s produces only 15 percent
of carbon dioxide emissions so it's a
lot of money spent up to upwards to 800
million dollars and for very very very
very little return and it wouldn't make
a difference so where all the pollution
is coming from like china
that's where the effort should go thank
you thank you uh yeah i'm gonna add uh
to this here which i was kind of
surprised on 380 million dollars being
collected on a carbon tax
and you know something i look at it
years ago when i was in another party we
cared about the um
and i'm not knocking anyone today i'm
just saying when i was with another
party i'm not gonna mention but we care
about the elderly we care about the
working people we care about trying not
to tax them and taking more money out of
their pockets so they can feed their
families pay their rents
and put food on the table
and then i seen the light over the years
when i realized that
they weren't doing that no more they
weren't fighting for the working people
they weren't fighting for the elderly
they weren't fighting they didn't care
we taxed everything that moved
and when i switched over into the
republicans i realized that
um
i want to maintain i want to be able to
spend my own money i want to protect the
elderly i want to protect the uh working
people
this here
tax
takes
money out of hard-working people's
pocket when we think we're going after
the businesses we're not what we're
doing is we're redistributing that money
because they're going after the
consumers to pick up the cost
on this here because we're going to tax
them on carbon but yet there's no remedy
to fix it
okay we're going to take their money and
then automatically most uh americans
think oh all of a sudden at the time the
cabin's gone it's we we got their money
they're carbon free until next year so
we'll tax them again
okay so this mentality has been going on
too long
al gore is living like a king
off of this dream of climate change
and dr flying around in big planes and
meanwhile everyone else is following him
everyone else is saying oh oh that's the
way to go and he's living in a big 20
room mansion or whatever he's living in
okay uh but we're falling like
puppets i fell into the dream with the
solar system
okay i fell into that thinking i was
going to save my family money and let me
tell you right now i might have saved
107 a month but it's not what they told
me it was going to do
and i got 30 panels on my house that's
totally different off a carbon so what
i'm trying to tell you is that
this is a feel good
legislation
and this here
this house resolution makes a difference
on telling the federal government enough
is enough on redistributing people's
money
and this is the first step in the right
direction
thank you
okay without that seeing that there's no
one else the motion on the floor and h.r
is ought to pass
and i'm going to ask the clerk to take a
representative moffatt
yes sir not to pass okay representative
yes
representative kat zakoros yes
representative rollins yeah
representative delanis yes
representative notter yes
representative foster yes representative
yes representative harley representative
levitt yes representative massimilia no
representative piedra no representative
query no
representative jack no representative
oregon no representative gallagher
no
representative
representative lawton
no
okay um and then you pass that off to
representative foster
to do is who's going to do the uh
minority report on the
are you going to do a minority
representative welkowitz would do the
minority
okay
i'm gonna close the um
exec session on hr17
give me a second to catch up 11 to 10.
okay
i'm going to open up the executive
session on hcr7 representative moffat
you elbowed me said you had something to
say
okay
thank you mr chair
on
hcr
7 which is the
concurrent resolution
to reinforce support for the nation of
israel in the embassy location
i
uh was able to hear uh only part of the
do you have a motion oh i'm sorry uh
i'm speaking to my motion before i make
my motion my motion is ought to pass
sorry mr chair
represent
i'll second i have another amendment to
okay
we have a motion on the floor ought to
pass
uh and it was made by representative
moffat second by representative de
chaise uh where's your
okay
okay um
are you uh making a motion
uh i motion ought to pass on this
amendment
okay do we have a second now
i do we have a second on the amendment i
second the amendment okay representative
welkowitz
no the branch yeah
yes yeah so i'm sorry of course it is
okay uh you want to speak to your
amendment representative yes uh so
as somebody that has studied uh
geopolitics and world history uh
obviously i'm a big nerd if i'm 20 years
old and i've become a state rep already
so
my knowledge of the conflict
i don't feel comfortable
picking aside in the israeli-palestinian
conflict
what this amendment does it reaffirms
our strong support for the jewish people
and our truest ally in the middle east
the nation of israel but it also adds
that the new hampshire general court
recognizes the right of the palestinian
people to exist and it also says that we
support the israeli palestinian peace
process i think we can all agree that
peace
should be the solution uh should be the
final resolution in the
the the middle east uh we want peace uh
and and i think we can all agree on that
um i don't think it's our place to be
picking a side in this conflict at least
with the china house resolution it's a
very clear
authoritarian country oppressing these
occupied regions but we we would like
to support the peace process and we
don't feel the need to uh intercede in
that
process well does this does this replace
keeping the embassy okay
uh do you recognize representative chase
yeah so um the way i'm i'm reading this
amendment is are you are you replacing
on the original resolution lines two
through
eight with what the amendment is uh
lines seven through fourteen so line
seven through fourteen of the amendment
is replacing lines two through eight of
the current resolution
i i also forgot to add thank you for
bringing that up uh
my knowledge of the conflict in the the
middle east
in israel palestine is
uh the moving of the embassy and that
was the most controversial part in my
eyes of the resolution and it simply
strikes that part and and then enters uh
these new sections about the uh right of
the palestinian people to exist
and uh the peace process that we support
representatives um yeah it wasn't really
a question um i didn't realize i was
even asking a question but i appreciate
that you answered my question but um so
i'm just gonna speak to the amendment if
that's okay am i allowed to do that
thank you mr chairman um and thank you
for answering my questions still though
it was intended as a question i just
didn't know if we're allowed to do that
during it's technically debated
you can okay just want to make sure i'm
following committee and house rules and
everything um
so
i think i think it's extreme you know i
your heart's in the right place
representative but i think it's
extremely important that the us and that
this this body this general court um
reaffirmed the us's current policy
towards israel right with the testimony
that we heard here uh yesterday just
yesterday from from someone who's part
of the general court who is a jewish
american who is one of our colleagues um
you know
really explaining the history of why
israel exists really explaining the
plight of the jewish people really
explaining the second diaspora that
they've gone through with people going
back to their homeland or coming to
america i think it's important that this
body send a strong statement and really
support the nation of israel right
really support the historical capital of
jerusalem which is currently their
governing capital instead of having our
diplomats driving halfway across the
israeli nation to do their jobs and to
support the people of israel and i think
it's also important if it's also their
capital i mean i would i wouldn't want
the the jewish people the israeli state
to be saying that our you know that we
had a different capital somewhere else i
don't think that's fair at all we should
have common respect if they recognize
our capital we should recognize their
true capital and i think i just think
that when we get to the crux of this all
we're doing is we're supporting the
israeli state just because we're
supporting the israeli state doesn't
mean that other members can't have their
own opinions on the conflict or other
people that they may support are also
involved in that conflict i just think
this is a um it's a good strong
statement the way it is i don't think
the amendment's necessary i think it
waters down our statement um i think
strong support for the israeli people in
the israeli nation is important now more
than ever especially when we've seen
terrorist attacks in our own country and
terrorist attacks in the middle east
against these people historically but
even just recently um i think we should
i think constituents expect this
especially with some of the anti-semitic
comments that have come from some of our
own colleagues in both parties and i've
been quite clear and denounced all those
comments to
jewish supporters jewish granite staters
to my own constituents i think i think
they um you know we're supposed to be
honorable and i think it's beneath our
titles in our office i think it means
that some some members have not reached
a mantle of our office so i hope
everyone can go on record in the house
and really um have to explain to their
constituents
why they either agree strongly or
disagree with the current um the current
as drafted language for
hcr7 and i think the amendment um i
don't think it's necessary in this
situation
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman and i agree with
everything the previous representative
just said i also wanted to remind
everyone that yesterday when we heard
the testimony
this one of the sponsors uh
representative aaron um said that the
resolution was fine the way it is and
she did not appreciate the amendment
okay
i don't see anyone else so let's uh go
to a vote uh lester clerk to
take a vote on arthur pass on amendment
to hcr 7 number 2022-01
h
representative
nay on uh to pass for the amendment
are we doing otp
voting on the amendment we're voting on
okay thank you um and uh representative
lundgren no
representative cat secaurus no
representative rollins no
representative delemus no
representative ben uh sorry i'm i
representative foster no
representative
no representative
yes
representative ted
pedro
representative querrey
yes
representative
jack yes
gallagher
yes
representative toll
representative le branch
yes
representative lawton
representative
yes
and representative
no
i mean 10 11 i should say 10 11. eleven
okay uh the amendment fails uh they
ought to pass uh 10 to 11.
now
uh representative moffat you had a
motion or something
thank you mr i it earlier motioned uh
otp and i uh again motion otp on this
measure that's right we do we have a
motion on the floor ought to pass you
had already made that motion i was just
checking to see if you were alert
you know
which i know you were is this me
okay uh any conversations on the uh
octopass on hcr 7. i'll speak
representative moffat thank you mr i'll
speak to my motion
uh very quickly
israel is the only democracy in that
part of the world
and israel represents what's right with
the middle east not what's wrong with
the middle east
the embassy change has been supported
since the 1990s by both parties uh by
both republican and democrat
administrations the obama administration
supported
uh at least said they supported
the
transfer of the embassy from tel aviv to
jerusalem but they just never took
action on it finally we did take action
and we backed up our words with action
and moved the embassy to
jerusalem and his representative desche
said i think we need to honor
uh we shouldn't decide
where we put our diplomatic people we
should honor the
wishes of the host country in terms of
where their capital is
uh and again this is a resolution that
allows us to send a message uh as we did
earlier in the historic tradition of
this body to occasionally send
messages on things that we feel are
important
like this and messages add up so i would
encourage you to vote otp in this
measure uh thank you representative
representative
dulimus thank you
thank you mr chair i just wanted to say
that i i think i recall this being
bipartisan
i think i recall that that president
clinton uh had something to do with
wanting to move the capitol to jerusalem
and recognize jerusalem as the capital
city
for that nation and that
i don't see how this is a
a problem it's something that both sides
were
good with doing
so that that was i just wanted to
reiterate that because i know that we're
aware that this that this was something
that both democrats and republicans
approved of in the past
thank you okay thank you representative
[Music]
thank you mr chair
um i'm opposing this resolution i think
it's a great example of something that
we should not be considering
or weighing in on and i know our
colleagues disagree on this and i think
that's fine
this resolution and the last resolution
are
examples of issues of great import very
very complex issues
we're not
a
experts in those subject matters
that's not the purview of this committee
and b
as a committee and as an institution as
the house we have no power over those
matters
um so
i think that's a more overarching
problem with resolutions generally we
have these great debates in this
committee and and on the house floor
about the merits of the issues
frankly it doesn't matter
this i think
though some
some folks may disagree with me
or at least say they disagree with me
realistically this resolution and the
other resolutions that we consider here
today are going to do nothing they're
not going to move the needle at all
no one will ever read them
and frankly i don't think it's again
within the purview of the committee
especially with regard to international
affairs
for the
new hampshire house to weigh in on those
matters especially when they involve
very complex issues
and picking sides
on a very complex dispute so that's why
i'm going to oppose this resolution
thank you uh anyone else uh
representative chase
um i can i can uh i can certainly see
the viewpoint of the uh of the good
gentleman from i believe nashua correct
representative piedra
manchester my apologies i can understand
the uh the sentiments of the gentleman
from manchester but i still think it's
important that this body
voice its opinion on how our federal
government is handling international
affairs it affects all of our
constituents it affects our state within
this ever globalizing world and um i
think it's also important to like i said
after seeing some of the anti-semitic
statements from members of this general
court from both parties that um that we
show that as a body right that we
that we support the nation of israel and
um i think that's important i think it's
important that constituents see
how
uh their representatives stand on this
issue after some of the things some of
the terrible things that have been said
in public or online statements and um
i'm hoping that this is a bill that um
that we can well this is a resolution
that we can get behind because all we're
doing is just reaffirming that the way
the current setup is uh with the nation
of israel the way that we currently
recognize their capital and have our
embassy there which has been of
bipartisan consensus for the last nearly
30 years that the people who elected us
can see that we are reaffirming that
international policy of the us
government and i know we don't have
purview of that but this is the one way
we get to have a say in it right this is
the one way in any official capacity and
that's part of the responsibility of
this committee as state and federal
relations this is how we explain you
know this is this is our relationship
with the federal government this is the
committee that's responsible for
redressing the federal government of
this body's concerns and i think this is
a something that is important to the
people in new hampshire that's important
to this committee and its purview even
if it's limited and only symbolic i
think it's also important that the
people of new hampshire see that this
body is not ripe with anti-semitism that
the people here support any and all
people including including jewish people
okay
representative nada
um thank you mr chairman um i i just
wanted to say something because you
mentioned some uh representatives who
said anti-semitic statements and i need
to defend at least two of them because
they did not know that what they were
posting was considered anti-semitic
one of them um even wore a support
israel pin four terms ago which was
three terms before he was ever accused
so i just wanted that to be on record
thank you
thank you um
representative levette thank you chair
bal disarro
i mean
doesn't the buck stop here i mean isn't
this the committee
that gets the ball rolling on this i
mean we're in a position
to go forward with some important
legislation
i mean if we keep putting this aside
because of
us not having
privy to
international
decisions
it'll be stagnant and we'll get nowhere
i support this legislation and i'd like
to go forward well thank you yeah you're
right we are state and federal relations
and some people don't read the rules or
anything like that understand the duties
of the uh committee and i'm well aware
of that and
been hearing that for like 15 years and
we still move on and ignore it but thank
you uh anyone else representative
welkowitz
thank you i'd like to speak as a jewish
legislator
and a member of a group of jewish
legislators who tried to respond to
anti-semitism
and i appreciate support for israel i've
spent quite a bit of time in israel uh
in jerusalem in haifa
uh my father taught at the technion in
haifa i have many friends there um i
just want to say though that what is
difficult for me is this
mixing
often of anti-semitism
and political positions about israel
that american jews
discuss these things in great detail we
argue with our uncles we argue with our
friends
about policy
and uh that they are
complicated and nuanced issues in the
middle east and i just want to separate
and urge people to separate
the ideas of anti-semitism
and
absolute support for israel
that there will be
jewish legislators
who will say it's not such a good idea
to move
the um
the capitol to jerusalem some say it
should be in tel aviv some say it should
be in jerusalem we will disagree with
this so i just want to say there isn't a
uniform jewish response
to this as we move forward independent
of how i finally vote
on this
okay i'll get you here
representative loft yes mr chairman
representative lawton here
i just want to say regardless of how
i choose to vote on this today
i'm not
someone who's anti-semitic and i support
our jewish brothers and sisters
i
am going to be voting
no on this but i just wanted to be clear
that um i support you know everyone no
matter what their walk of life is if
they're jewish or whatnot
um
i i just feel like this is uh something
we shouldn't be supporting
all right thank you uh representative
loomis
thank you mr chair
every sabbath
i take the entire day and i do nothing
but study
i study and i rest and i i bathe myself
on
sabbath
every week
and i there's one particular gentleman
who i learn from
every week
and he is brilliant and he uh
lives in jerusalem and he actually
helped interpret the dead sea scrolls
uh he's very in touch with many of the
people in his
homeland
and when
i'll never forget because i was
surprised that he talked about anything
political at all but he
he
when the
capital was moved back to jerusalem
he described his great joy
and he described
the great joy
that the people that he knew
felt
at being validated and having their
capital in in the city where it belongs
anti-semitism
[Music]
the fact that the people
in
jerusalem and the people actually in
israel were so
elated
so they felt
validated
and they were they were thrilled and
i i have my i like to think that i have
at least my little finger on the pulse
so i just wanted to say that because i
don't want anyone in here to mistake
that
that the the people
in israel and especially in jerusalem
are not absolutely elated and thrilled
that their capital has been moved to
where it was supposed to be moved
decades ago
thank you
anyone else uh representative hogan
well thank you very much
chairman baldassaro first of all the
state of
israel is not a monolith there have as
many different opinions as many
different factions as
the united states or any other country
so not a unified entity and also not
everyone who lives in israel is
is jewish and not and of course
most jews live outside israel and um
so the jewish people in the state of
israel are not the same thing and
certainly you're not necessarily
condemning either if you disagree with
some of the policies but the other
thing was we were
generally from rochester said we have to
support just because of what
clinton
did when he was president which was uh
over 20 years a long time ago over 20
years ago and and or obama and you know
obama and clinton
may have been wrong about some things
which doesn't mean and just as uh
trump or
george george w bush or the elder bush
may not have also made mistakes that
doesn't necessarily mean you know we
democrats are not necessarily obligated
to replicate every
error that
obama or clinton made or also or even al
gore whose name came up in an earlier
bill
and just as like you're not obligated to
replicate every mistake that trump or
the bushes or other republicans have
made so that
we're not locked into position just
because of what a former democratic
president made so thanks
thank you anyone else representative
nada thank you mr chairman
i just uh
the representatives on both sides of the
aisle that were accused of anti-semitism
i know what they went through and i
would not want to be on the side of that
accusation
i just want to you might want to keep
that in mind when we vote
well thank you anyone else
okay there is a motion on the floor
on ought to pass
on
by representative moffitt on house
concurrent resolution seven
and i will ask the roll call the
collector take a roll call vote
on otpa representative moffat
i believe it's the emotion is otp
and
representative lundgren yes
representative katzacorus yes
representative rollins yes
representative delemus yes
representative notter
representative foster yes representative
yes representative harley
representative
no
representative piedra no
representative query no
representative jack no representative
oregon no representative gallagher no
representative
no
representative le branch
representative lawton no representative
yes
and representative
should be 12
okay we have a vote uh that
hci7 passed 12 to nine
okay
you know for the record there i did do
my dna and all this time i thought it
was 100 italian
and uh came back uh i don't know if
there's a conflict of interest from me
voting but came back five percent jewish
i don't know how that happened but
just for the record i thought
for the record mine came back five
percent italian yeah
yeah see that
oh i was i was shocked on how it came
back
and
my mother's in the grave there so i
wanted to tell her i said my what
happened but
you know
okay so we have that uh bill i'll close
that hcr7 committee report committee
reports
okay pardon me i've got to grab a couple
of those
okay we'll we'll wait until we're on on
track here
i'd rather get those out and so we're on
all right well there's hpr committee you
guys can fill okay
this one here is for fill this out
okay this one's for the majority so
right there
and then
okay
let me know when you're ready there
madam clark
what are we doing next we're on house
can cover resolution six
all righty
we all set up
huh
what's that
no
listen to me i'm the chairman we're
doing hcr 6.
all right
yeah 14-11 will be next 14-11 is next on
my thing
yeah
i got him in the same order we went
there's a couple of bills i still have
to find that i i got them here somewhere
yeah me too
okay we all set i'm going to open up the
executive session on house recovery
resolution six
and uh i'm looking for a motion
okay we have a motion to itl
the
okay we have a motion itl
by uh representative lebet and second by
second uh by tina we all set
representative molly okay
i dragged my foot on that there and
hoping you guys stepped up and made a
motion but i guess not
all right
okay so uh the motion is itl
okay thank you is there any uh comments
representative branch yes i think if we
spend any time on the spill i'm going to
lose my marbles
i'm going to tell you a few years can i
suck in that
yeah
a few years ago we passed this out of
committee here and uh i thought it was a
great
uh bill telling the united kingdom there
to turn back those marbles or whatever
was stolen and we had a lot of a lot of
people came in and testified
and there were greek on both parties
so i felt you know that it was only
right to do the right thing there and
saving the position in new hampshire is
to speak on behalf of the greek people
in our state
so that's why i dragged my feed on it uh
you know before i went to itl so but
we're in itl so
yes
i know personally i agree with the
resolution i'll probably vote against
the itl motion but we can just go on to
a roll call okay well i appreciate you
we got to move you into this gym and
then okay uh uh is there anyone else
that uh wants to speak on behalf
cnn nobody else then let's move to uh
itl on house recovery resolution six
okay ito
uh representative moffat yes to itl
representative lundgren yes
yes
representative
representatives
okay um are you gonna do a minority okay
so without any objections remove this
consent calendar okay uh
for consent
all right that was htr six let me make
that note concerned
i gotta go through all these make sure
all my eyes
right and then well i got notes in too
um okay and then i'm going to close the
hcr 6 executive session
no yeah there's no minority they're not
going to
this was uh
john robert goes down here
representative
hcr6 let me give it give me a second
we'll go to the next one here
20-1
okay
on the next one uh which will be hb
i'm going to open up the executive
session on hb 1411
and representative foster you had a uh
amendment i mean uh
yes i have a an amendment on it for the
date okay do we we all have a copy of
that amendment right yeah i handed them
out yesterday
does anyone have a um wasn't there
another
okay wait first of all there's a motion
on ought to pass we're going to go to
the you're going to make a motion on the
amendment
right okay what's your motion on
i'd like to make a motion um
to amend house bill 1411
uh and
give us one second and you'll be
speaking to it okay who moved otp on the
and then second by uh representative uh
yeah
the amendment is uh
we have a motion on the floor
on the out to pass on amendment 0 2 0 2
they need 11.
anybody need one
representative ms maskeville you all
you all set okay uh you want to speak to
your amendment uh sure uh yes um
so this amendment all it's doing is
changing the um
effective date on it because i missed
this um when it was originally drafted
and there the original um
effective date was july 1st 2022 and i
think that's pushing things
so all the the amendment does is move it
okay anyone else want to speak to the
amendment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to uh
take a roll call on out to pass on
okay
uh
and that's an otp on that right
right right okay uh representative
moffat
[Music]
14-11
right
okay
is this an hb
yes
sorry sorry guys i was not prepared for
oh okay yeah he wasn't in the room okay
next one um
representative query
yes
representative jack yes
representative oregon yes
representative gallagher yes
representative toll
yes
representative
so
uh these who seconded that oh that was
uh chase
thank you
okay uh representative foster you had a
uh yes i'd like to make a motion
for
[Music]
house bill
1411 relative to the transparency of
federal operations
agency operations in new hampshire
ought to pass okay thank you before i
move on is there any other amendments uh
yes uh i'm the amendment man today yeah
uh and i would like to apologize
beforehand i don't think i made enough
copies for everybody on the committee
did we get a second on that otp
yeah
well we're not on the ogtpa yet
no not yet
yep
yeah
we'll be back out of recess at uh 11 30
uh two so let's try to make this quick
where's that where forward that at his
oh
yes
you
oh
actually
yes uh thank you mr chair uh this
amendment's a very simple one it strikes
uh
well
one and a half lines from the uh current
uh legislation
uh
i agree with the bill a 100
there were some reservations on this
side of the room about uh refugee
resettlement
we don't want it to become a political
issue we don't want uh to un unjustly uh
track these individuals and i talked to
the prime sponsor of the bill and
it is my understanding that he is okay
with this amendment
uh in that this can get us a lot more
votes on this bill and it makes it a lot
more unanimous i don't think it will be
unanimous but it gets us more votes in
thank you i'm a little confused on
whether the prime minister was
in favor but you want to speak to that
yes it will um and i was in favor of of
of this amendment to begin with but
after speaking with several of the
co-sponsors last night and a number of
the the caucus members on our side um i
decided to be against this and move the
language forward the way it is
there's concern from these people that
this information is um will be useful in
identifying um for education purposes
and for
resource purposes for
um the state that you know what they're
looking at
from a budgetary standpoint so
um
i'm going to be against this amendment
okay thank you
anyone else want to speak on this uh you
already one sec uh did you have your
i'm sure i
um
because i was not even on the hearing
for this bill and i just saw this
amendment a second ago i
i mean i think general idea is good i'm
not sure in the original bill what a
federal foreign relocation since from my
understanding is
usually refugees they're made into the
country and then it's usually private
private
organizations who actually handle the
nuts and bolts of relocating them and
finding a place to live so um
so i'm still kind of fuzzy so i'm just
fuzzy about like whether this would have
the desired effect if we left it in
since but
thanks okay thank you uh the branch you
made the motion on that octopus who made
huh
representative massimilia okay yeah she
was the second
all right
okay representative moffatt
uh thank you miss chair so i if i could
ask the uh sponsor of this amendment to
just very quickly once he once again uh
explained this and i ask this again just
so i understand uh partly because i i
vote first and
and uh we we didn't have a chance to
talk about this in caucus and i note
that representative foster the sponsor
was for it and now he's kind of leaned
against it so
uh if you could just take a few moments
and once again just
clearly explain
your amendment and the intent
thank you for the question uh
so as the bill is currently written it
asks the federal government to share
information on the total number of
facilities in the state it has permanent
staff assigned in the state temporary
staff surveillance operations currently
going on in the state federal
investigations warrants served no knock
warrants served in federal arrests those
are all things i agree with
this amendment simply strikes the last
data point that we're asking the federal
government to share with us about
foreign
refugee relocations in new hampshire
i i just am concerned that
that number will be used as a political
football
in elections
we don't want to be
unduly trafficking tracking these
individuals when we're trying to
integrate them into our society
and i i that's my one concern with the
bill as currently written
thank you very much
thank you is there any uh more
discussion
um i i of course support i'll be posing
the amendment myself uh
but
uh because i support basically what you
said in the responses and co-sponsors
there
on the uh the bill there because there's
issues here i think it's very important
for the uh cities and towns to know uh
what's been coming going on in their
uh cities and towns it makes a big
difference on their uh how much money
they got to raise their taxes on for
education
okay or for services and other things
there so we owe it to the taxpayers to
uh make sure that it's transparent
representative chase
yeah i i i just wanted to say um
the point is transparency and it's just
a number um i couldn't see how it could
become a uh a
political football personally i mean you
know i think it's good to know how many
for example and it's something that is
even reported in the press too right i
mean we saw what was it was it 50 um
afghani uh refugees who fought alongside
u.s soldiers on a you know a
two-decade-long mission who are
relocated here i think it's good for
that kind of information to be published
today who of our allies are coming back
to this country and are going to be um
you know assimilated into our society i
think it's um this is just asking for a
certain amount of transparency and we
also can't forget too if the federal
agency wants to they can just say no if
they feel as if it could violate some
amount of privacy of the of the refugees
being sent here but even still um
it's just a number and you know i would
i would hope people would understand you
know what what it takes to uh to be re
resettled into this country as a refugee
uh the extensive process specifically
and what we've just seen with afghani
refugees who you know quite literally
defended u.s soldiers on foreign soil so
thank you thank you
seeing none last
the clerk to go for a roll call vote
on art to pass
h which is an amendment for hb 1411.
okay representative moffat nay in the
amendment
representative lundgren no
representative rollins
representative delemus no
representative notter
representative foster
no
representative
representative harley
representative levitt nate
representative
yes
representative gallagher
yes representative tolle
yes
representative lebranch yes
representative lawton
yes
representative
uh mr chair can we motion recons
reconsideration on the previous
amendment
yeah
um
you have to be on the prevailing side uh
what's the vote
eleven yays ten nays and actually
phyllis
did you make a mistake on the vote
okay so you want representative kat you
want to reconsider the vote
okay there is a motion on the uh to
reconsider
uh the vote
first of all let me clarify something uh
the vote on ought to pass passed and
that vote was
11 to 10.
and there is a motion to reconsider
because one of our representatives made
a mistake on the vote and out of respect
and i've done that for both sides before
then
there
is there a second on your motion i'll
second
representative uh seconds the motion
i'll ask any discussion
any discussion on it
okay um i i'll discuss um
just as a reminder so people aren't
confused about the procedure we're
saying yes to reconsider to go back and
reconsider the original question
just so everyone's aware and the
majority caucus
what i'm going to do is ask a show
a show of hands the motion is
ought to pass on a reconsider if you
support or reconsider you're going to
say yes if you oppose it you're going to
mr chair i mean you're going to put your
hand up for yes and then i'll go to who
opposes mr chair yes speak briefly yes
go ahead i just want to say i'm going to
support this motion as a courtesy uh to
the other member all right
thank you okay so if you support
reconsidering uh put your hand up yes
looks unanimous okay unanimous okay
okay
uh now we're back to the uh motion by
representative little branch and i
assume it's been seconded again by
representative massimilia
in on a ought to pass
for
h
you know if there's no discussion i'll
ask the clerk once again to take a roll
call
okay
representative moffat
nay on the amendment okay
representative lundgren no
representative rollins no
delemus no representative notter
representative foster
representative deshay
representative harley
representative levitt
representative massimo
yes
representative pedro yes representative
quarry yes uh representative jack yes
um
yes
yes okay i thought i'd have to
reconsider again representative
gallagher
yes uh representative tolle yes
representative lebranch yes uh
representative lawton
yes representative
yes and representative
yes okay so that is 11 to 10 and the um
you have me know rather
right opposing correct yeah so there are
there are 11 nays 10 yays and the otp
fails
or that's your purview not me 11 yeah i
just wanted to make sure yeah
i just
what was this one
okay so the amendment uh on um was 11 to
10 which failed
okay
let me just make a note on the last one
okay so here's what i've got
uh give us a chance just to catch up
we're doing good
i just want to make my note on
all right we have a motion on the floor
uh
ought to pass uh representative foster
do you want to change art to pass as
amended
yes i do
wait a minute disregard that no
disregard that
forget what i just said
um
we're on out the pass
otp
are there any other amendments um a
point of order mr chair
point of order um did we not pass an
original amendment to change the
effective date which would mean we do
need to so so and i would um i would
reaffirm my seconding for the updated
motion of optipass as i mentioned
yeah let me get it
okay here we go
as you see we got stacks here i'm trying
okay um
we have a motion on the floor right
ought to pass as amended
uh with amendment
2022-01948 is that what you want to make
okay and do we have a second i'll second
okay
uh
well that otp
a was already uh moved by foster and
seconded by levitt well no because we
didn't have a member with the amendment
passed yet it was first thought to pass
and then we had it we passed that right
but we didn't go to the out to pass that
amendment we had another amendment we
had to do first okay so now we're back
to our pass as amended i i seconded but
it could be if representative levitt
really wants the second he can
you want a second
representative
okay and then i'm going to write that
back in
okay the motion uh on the floor is do
you want to speak to your motion or not
to pass
i had to amend it
the original intent of this bill and the
current
intent of this bill is to provide some
transparency
as far as what federal agencies are
doing within our state
security but to take all that
information because there's a great many
federal agencies that have policing
power
and to take all that information and put
it into a single place where the
citizens of our state can look and see
it
and
get rid of
some of the speculation as to what's
happening and what what agencies are
doing
and to give people a better
understanding of what our federal
government is doing here in new
hampshire to try to improve state and
federal relations statewide
okay anyone else want to add
representative branch
i want to say that i completely agree
with uh the member on the other side of
the room
i
ran on a platform of transparency and i
think that we deserve to know what the
federal government is doing in our
country are doing in our country
obviously doing in our state uh and
that's why i will be voting in favor of
the underlying bill
thank you anyone else
anyone else not seeing that there's no
other
anyone speaking out i guess it will go
to or not to pass as amended on
amendment zero one nine four h and i'll
ask the clerk to do a roll call vote
okay representative moffat
yes to otpa
representative lundgren yeah
representative kat zakoros yes
representative
thank you
representative harley
representative levitt
representative massimilla
representative piedra no
representative query no
representative jack no
representative
no
representative lebranch
yes
representative lawton
representative welkowitz
no
and representative
yes
okay we have a uh vote of 14 to 7 on our
passes amendment on hb 1411 passes
and are we going to have
are we going to have a minority report
on this no no okay so it'll be just the
okay i'm closing the hearing on the
executive session on
1411.
okay um you know what i'll do is i'll
read this after i get done here um okay
so all right that's one years for that
that and that is seven
no next chairman hr
okay there's no amendment
all right we're on uh hr i'm going to
open up the executive session on h.r 18
and representative lundgren you had a
all right there's a motion on the itl
and i'll second that
um would you like to speak to your
motion
yes i just think we're overstepping our
okay thank you are there any other
i
would like to speak in opposition to the
itl motion to hr18
i think that when the 13th amendment did
pass
having this exception in
pass stricter laws to put people in
prison to use as slave labor as we heard
in the testimony yesterday
some of these states were
introducing the black code
to to arrest recently freed slaves and
putting them back into slavery and then
selling that slave labor to the
plantations that they had just been
freed from
i i believe that this was uh intentional
when the 13th amendment was passed and i
think it's time that we asked the
congress to
remove that exception from the 13th
amendment i i know that probably won't
happen but
i think that our state should be taking
a stand against slave labor
i know in california
yesterday a question was brought up
about qualifications given to these
prisoners uh doing slave labor and the
example that comes to the top of my mind
is
california forcing prisoners to fight
wildfires
but when they are freed from
prison they do not have the
qualifications
to become a firefighter and they have
the criminal background that prevents
them from becoming a firefighter so
we're putting these prisoners
in harm's way trying to to fight these
fires and we're not even giving them the
qualifications to fight these fi fight
the fires after the release from prison
so i think that there's a lot of issues
with the current uh 13th amendment and
that we should close the loophole so
that there is no slave labor in the
united states
okay thank you is there anyone else that
wants to speak on this bill
i'll be more than happy to do it
i i support the itl and the reason why i
mean you talk about firemen
i wasn't a fireman either i fought many
fires in floods in california
okay and got my regular minecore salary
as a marine
many volunteers fight fires and help out
and everything else we're talking
prisoners
we're talking people have done that done
crime
so
i'm not going to be easy on crime and
try to be nice because you go to jail
and then all of a sudden we want you to
just sit there maybe collect the sun for
the next four six twenty or your
lifetime hang out in the sun
let's give you a fair wage but we're
gonna cost the taxpayers uh feed you
okay board you uh and uh put you on you
know room and board
um in money for everything else for your
while you're in prison that's what this
is about
there's slavery we use slavery here i'm
called a racist every two years when i
run for state rep
okay and yet you know
we're so easy to throw out that word
slavery
you know because you've done the crime
there so let's pat him on the back you
know maybe give him a cushion a mattress
or something like that and maybe let him
get the sun tanning lotion or something
i don't understand this here why we
would not support something like this
here on the itl uh why we were saying
that we're treating prisoners as slaves
do you want them to sit around
i mean this just makes no sense to me
i'm sorry new hampshire has a reputation
you do the time you do the crime and
then they should be paying for their uh
you know restitution and they should be
paying for their stay in prison they did
the crime not the people are the victims
i'll leave it at that thank you
anyone else want to speak on the itl
against
no thank you i'm gonna since there's no
one else that wants to speak
uh i'm gonna ask
the collector make a
do a roll call vote on itl on house
resolution 18.
okay
representative moffat
yes to itl representative lundgren yes
representative katz yes representative
rollins yeah representative delemus yes
representative notter yes representative
foster yes representative desha
representative leavitt
oh
no
okay
uh representative pedro no
representative query no
representative jack no representative
uh yes
representative gallagher
no
representative
representative lebranch
no
representative lawton
representative
no and representative
nine
yep everyone was present right nine
twelve to nine
okay the vote was twelve to nine um the
itl passes in um representative lundgren
you'll be doing a majority report is
there a minority report
outstanding i appreciate that this is a
good one
i i will make a minority report just
because there's members of my
independent caucus on the
minority web best set to him
thank you very much this is a good
election man
okay
um we're all set on that let's catch up
um
hr 18
12 to nine
okay we said lundgren and then we said
the branch
okay
all righty
okay we're going to move to
the
constitutional amendment
concurrent resolution
32 representation
representative duchess you had a motion
to make yeah i'd like to motion itl on
cacr32
we have a motion to itl on um 32
constitution number 32.
we have a second representative rollins
seconds the amendment and would you like
to speak to your ito
yeah i'll be brief i mean we i committee
you know for people that weren't in
committee yesterday committee asked me
questions for probably about 27 minutes
straight and um but they were good and
it was a great stimulating conversation
many of us sat here
for three hours
and listen to testimony but what we have
to remember about the testimony that we
heard yesterday is the constitutional
ramifications were not touched even the
people who did the mental gymnastics
regarding how the economic and the
logistical situation could be remedied
at the end of the day we have to we took
an oath to the u.s constitution to the
state constitution that oath recognizes
by taking that oath to both
constitutions and with both
constitutions recognizing uh joint
sovereignty over issues in this country
it doesn't make sense for us to be
violating that oath as a as a as
legislators there's also
then you know people supporting this we
enter into a very gray area regarding
whether or not that is rebellion and
whether or not that is uh that's grounds
for removal from office which is a very
scary thing to think about um it's
something that would disenfranchise
voters it's something that is uh to me
it's a um you know should we really be
forcing not only the us constitution
into a uh
into you know disarray but should we
also be forcing this body into a
situation where we have to start asking
the question should a legislator be
sitting um within this body and you know
we discussed that at length yesterday
and um
i think i think the constitutional
argument against it was quite sound i
think the argument that was brought
forward by members of the committee was
quite sound and i don't think anyone who
testified yesterday in favor could
properly address that other than if they
believe that the u.s constitution is um
has no legal authority which it quite
clearly does the us constitution is the
utmost legal authority in this country
so with that i would encourage every
legislator on this committee to um to
encourage the body to recommend to the
body that we unanimously um strike down
cacr 32 right because we've we embarked
on a constitutional process starting
with the introduction of this and the
hearing
and um this is when we now enter into
the constitutional situation of
you know what happens if legislators
support this and i would i would hope
that that's just not a question we even
have to address at any point in any time
going forward thank you
thank you uh you know i i i'm just gonna
add
i i agree with this here carl you know
but the thing is why i'm not supporting
it is because there's no plan what
happens after
there's nothing in place here what
happens to our elderly what happens to
the working people what happens to the
people are paid in social security what
happens if people work in massachusetts
what happens to the military
on our borders with the air the tankers
what are
national support that we have with our
military here
on the equipment that was sent to us
paid by the federal government there's
no plan
i mean yeah we all believe many of us
believe the federal government is a
little out of control but we're
fortunate no because new hampshire is
fortunate for many years standing up on
their own we don't have a sales tax we
have a property tax we kicked back we
went against the federal government on
medical marijuana we went we're the only
state in the country without a seat belt
law
we don't we want to get you know on the
federal government beliefs on riding
motorcycles with helmets that's right so
we do fight them you know uh the federal
government but there's no plan how do we
put this together
no nothing do we throw grandma out of
the nursing homes now because we can't
afford it
you know what i'm saying i mean think
about what we're doing here
i mean i honestly when i'm dreaming at
night i think it's a great idea but when
i wake up and come back to reality
i realize that there's just no damn way
general stocks rolling over in his grave
that fought for america not just for new
hampshire
okay and i'll leave it at that but
representative you have something
yes if we
if we uh if we secede even though we
still the state constitution we we're
not protected by anything in federal law
the federal constitution so you know
there's
no like with grandma in the nursing home
there's uh no more medicare
medicaid or medicare there's no federal
highway funding there's no first
amendment no second amendment no 13th
amendment you know and
the list goes on and on so like we're
not we're then not protected by anything
that the federal government
does that's actually good which is a lot
of things or we're not protected by
anything in the u.s constitution which
uh
and it's the u.s constitution is a lot
harder to change because you have to get
uh
well
almost all 50 states i think 38 out of
50 rather than just one but so
um
it's just a
it's just a very very risky thing to do
and also of course as a state we're not
really prepared to go out and know as an
independent nation anyway so
that's uh
those are as good of reasons as any to
vote against this constitutional
amendment and of course also just
putting this in our constitution really
it's unclear what legal effect that
would have
whether
that the we can't necessarily guarantee
the other 49 states or the federal
government who just go along with it so
and there's nothing in the u.s
constitution that allows the session
anyway so
it's
thank you uh representative
representative shakes yeah i just want
to point out um uh
three things real briefly thing number
one is by adding a subsection a the
subsection a that they propose it uh it
directly conflicts with what the uh with
what article seven part one of the new
hampshire state constitution already
says it says that we recognize the u.s
constitution and the congress and its
authority right now we're adding a
subsection a and in that subsection a it
directly conflicts so all of a sudden we
have two parts of the same article of
our state constitution that is in direct
confliction with each other that's the
first thing the second thing is i'm
gonna i agree with the um representative
horrigan's kind of his sentiments but i
disagree with how he's characterizing
them because secession is not a
constitutional authority of any
legislator in this body um no state
kansas city no state ever seceded
according to the legal presence
established by the supreme court after
the civil war right that's quite clear
in white v texas 1869 no state ever
seceded there were pro-union governments
that kept running the actual legitimate
governments of southern states during
during rebellion right because we're
calling this a session how it's legally
recognized is that they were in
rebellion and the last thing is the u.s
supreme court does recognize rebellion
as also being a peaceful process right
dennis versus u.s 1951 the chair of the
communist party could not run and stand
for government or get elected for
government even because he supported he
supported rebellion against the u.s
constitution and its legitimate
government so um
this is a um this this amendment this is
the first time um actually we you know
this is a historical moment believe it
or not because this is the first time
that any state legislature has discussed
in any committee or legislative body
a
binding
binding secession right other things
that you see on the news regarding
secession like for example in texas or
even vermont from time to time does it
those are non-binding you know
resolutions right similar to our hr's or
you know our house concurrent
resolutions those are non-binding
they're symbolic this
this is binding
right and so this is actually the last
people who debated such a binding
resolution were people who rebelled and
took up arms against the u.s
constitution and the federal government
right the confederacy and to me um i
think it deserves a resounding
no i think uh governor sununu says it
quite well right when you hear crazy
knocking at the door you slam it shut
this is crazy
this is unconstitutional this is a
violation of our oath
um
i wish that some of the folks who had
introduced this had thought more in
depth and consulted with legal scholars
consulted with you know
experts on this issue but um it to me
it's it's just quite clear after
speaking to numerous legal scholars
after sitting down and preparing for the
hearing for an hour with the legal
scholar who's you know internationally
renowned for helping secessionist
movements and people in rebellion form
constitutions and um in our
constitutional system
there is no way for us to have secession
right secession is not something that
can be entertained rebellion against the
u.s constitution is not allowed and even
legislators peacefully proposing such is
still a form of rebellion and now we
enter into the gray area of
if someone is supporting such a measure
then what what is our job do we have to
enforce the 14th amendment section 3
right and to not think that someone you
know in either party is going to maybe
go after someone else in the other party
for possibly violating their
constitutional oath um i think i think
it would be um
i think it would almost be a little bit
ignorant not to assume that right so i
think people need to be cognizant of
that that this could have it could it
could end up turning into a political
mess
where our house is having to really
decide you know setting essentially a
legal precedent for this state of um of
what happens uh by supporting this and i
don't think that's something that
we want fellow members in our house to
have to deal with
so
uh with that i i'll i'll yield my time
well thank you uh you know most people
that don't
that you know testify on this stuff here
don't even read the constitution and i i
wish they would uh educate themselves
more on the constitution they just go
off the wall and wow this sounds great
let's let's do that and it's really not
you know
constitutionally right to be able to
move forward with something like this
sounds good
you know what i mean i think it's a
great mr mr chair i mean when i was in
high school i always thought it was a
cool concept but then i went to college
and now i'm a legislator and i learned
about the constitution the ramifications
and i said
it's just not plausible and if you're a
military guy of course your vote never
expired now you took during the military
to defend the country foreign and
domestic you know i mean so uh
okay anyone else representing the branch
thank you mr chair even if we entertain
this idea
it would be in conflict to another
section i believe it's the same section
of the new hampshire constitution that
says we are part of the united states so
we would have one section that says we
are part of the united states and then
another section that says we're not even
if we entertain this idea it does not
make sense
i agree matter of fact something i
didn't even think about we take our oath
and in the constitution we take the oath
of the
new hampshire in the u.s uh
america we take a duel out right
oh representative foster
yeah i just want to go on the record um
this is probably one of the hardest
votes i've made it's not easy for me
um
because when i came in here yesterday
and i saw the people that were
standing up to to do this and now it's a
small minority within our society
many of those people were
you know they're not
they don't share the same views i share
they don't share the same
things that i share but
when i looked at that i didn't look and
see a group of people who were bad or
evil who who we needed to shut up or put
down and i do see in our society a trend
when
we have our neighbors who disagree with
us
on certain issues whether they be
political and so forth
to push them down to say
no we don't even want to hear from you
either but they had an opportunity to
speak yesterday
um
i also didn't come at this from the
angle of fear so
you know
yeah you could be called the traitor
perhaps it's unconstitutional that would
be for courts to decide there's a whole
bunch of constitutional issues and so
forth
um
but
i trust
i mean if i was to vote
in favor of of moving this forward i
would trust that my neighbors would make
good decisions and i don't think i do
not see 7 out of 10 or approximately 7
out of 10 of my neighbors voting for
this because like you said
there is no plan
and that's what deeply concerns me here
it
they have an idea and they have very
legitimate fears and concerns
that
their rights may be getting taken away
that their voice may be getting silenced
and
so
in in
in reality
the actions taken to silence those
people probably brought this resolution
forward but it is binding and that
concerns me too when there's no real
i could
vote to kick it to my neighbors and say
here what do you guys want to do what do
you think you know um
but
i would
in reality rather see
something brought if
the condition can persists and and
something um you know and or worsens
okay
the
the fear
that is involved here
the overreach of our federal government
which drives this whole thing
is it going to get worse i don't know i
can't predict that
okay are we going to marginalize groups
of people
that
don't share our views or maybe have
orientations or whatever you know are we
gonna marginalize those people because
they don't agree with us
i don't wanna ever do that i want all
people to have a voice
but at the same time
if there's no plan to it it's very
dangerous it's like taking a leap
without having a plan of how you're
going to land
um and so
with that
i have a very difficult choice here
because i want to support
liberty and i want to support
people's rights
but at the same time
i don't think we're at a point yet where
we need to
withdraw from our federal government and
if we do we need a plan to do so so
i
am not going to be voting in favor of
this
well thank you representative is there
representing the branch
sorry i i've been talking a lot today
but i would like to echo a lot of the
points of representative foster uh
i i agreed with a lot of what was said
at yesterday's hearing about you know
the war on drugs and
occupations of other countries and
killing innocent civilians in other
countries there's a lot that i disagree
with the federal government on and and
the federal overreach on states issues
i can agree with that and i can agree
with some of the sentiment that they uh
have expressed yesterday
i myself come from the immigrants of
people from quebec and i support the
quebec independence movement and there's
a whole list of reason for why i support
that and the federal overreach of the
canadian government
but
another aspect that i'd like the
committee to think about and as rep
foster
said i don't think that seven out of ten
of my neighbors would vote for this uh
and i think it's a very small group and
we have to consider the cost of having
this uh
binding referendum uh this election
season because putting that question on
the ballot and counting all those votes
does cost money to put on the ballot
thank you i would also think by sending
this to the
voters
that
we would i myself would look incompetent
and the reason why i would feel i would
look incompetent that i'm sending
something that is not well thought out
that we really never thought about a
plan like we said earlier on how to
implement this here
it's just not there and i i honestly
think i would look stupid to my concern
i'm not running again so i don't care
but i would think i would look like an
idiot because there's no plan everyone
that was here really passionate
and i respected i knew a lot of them
that were out there i've been on the
liberty side for 15 years but
i rather have passed something that's
you know
with something that's not
unconstitutional and
goes against everything that we stand
for and for all those veterans that died
fighting for our freedom you know what i
mean because general stock and all
wasn't just about new hampshire it was
about the whole country they fought for
so
now leave it that representative yeah i
just want to point out one thing we're
using the word referendum new hampshire
doesn't have referendums this is part of
a constitutional process you have to
look at it we're running a race right
and there's different mile you know
there's different points that you reach
in the race so you know you start the
race by introducing the bill right mile
one is the hearing mile two is here
mile three
is um is the house floor mile four is
the senate floor mile five
is the people right kicking it back to
them the people get to have the final
say
but we by pushing when we push this
along each mile right those who aid in
that process are aiding and finishing
the race
that's at least how i come at it from
the perspective and some constitutional
scholars that i talk to there were some
that said well maybe not necessarily
because intent matters the bigger
question and this is this is and this is
the ultimate thing though that i'm
trying to get back to that i said
earlier is
we enter into this gray area right are
we going to consider intent when making
a vote or outcome of making a vote right
what is the outcome outcome of pushing
this forward or intent of well i
intended to push this forward just
because i thought it was a more
democratic process well we're not
we're pushing forward a constitutional
process it's already embarked we're in
the middle of it we're right now we're
at the halfway point right after this
gets through this committee no matter
the vote
we've gone half we've gone halfway i
forgot about the senate committee the
senate committee will get this too so
it's a six mile race but
you know so i look at this and i say are
we going to be aiding and helping finish
this race of new hampshire secession
or are we going to say no and adhere to
the constitutional oath into the
constitutional precedence established
and i think that's the i think that's
the biggest thing we have to consider
and to think that there might not be
members of the house that will turn this
into a political issue of saying someone
voted for secession now we're in this
gray area and they need to be taken to
court to find out whether or not that
was rebellion i think i i i hope members
don't do that but that's a very
plausible possibility there's 400 people
to not think that one in 400 people will
exploit this for a political reason
i would you know it's the sad reality of
politics so i would hope that people
really really think this through before
they decide that they want to enter into
a constitutional gray area into limbo of
what what what is to happen going
forward regarding the 14th amendment
section 3. and that's all that's all i
have to say uh to finish
representative moffatt
uh thank you mr i just want to
acknowledge the comments of our actually
our two youngest uh
from each side of the room youngest
representatives
uh and along those lines i think steve
duprey was 18 when he was a state rep
but uh kyle jones
was 18. kyle jones was 17 when he was
elected so representative louise you're
one of the youngest but anyway i just
want to thank you for your
salient i think comments and certainly
uh thank you representative des for all
your work on this i'm real glad the
chair didn't ask me to do what he asked
you to do because there was some you
took some heat yesterday but you're
you're a tough guy i want to thank
representative foster for his comments
and uh some a lot of you were here last
night and towards the end i i did take a
few moments to try to explain the
process to the many people who are here
that last night was a hearing and today
would be an exec session where we would
make a recommendation
i just pulled my magic device out and we
are live on youtube and there are three
people watching so
i just wanted to share that and and
thank you
thank you um
is there anything anyone else would go
to a vote
i'm looking around the room
i don't see anyone else
i'm going to ask the clerk to
do a roll call on the motion itl
on constitution american current
okay
uh representative moffitt
yes to itl
representative lundgren yes
representative katzacorus yes
representative rollins yes
representative
yes
representative notter yes
representative
yes
representative harley yes representative
levitt oh yes
representative massimo yes
representative pedro yeah
a representative query yes
representative jack yes
representative oregon yes representative
gallagher
yes
representative
representative welkowitz yes and
yes
24-19 21-0 okay this will be on the
regular calendar anyways because it has
to be a roll call vote
24 nothing let me see
24. and uh represents uh you're doing
the uh
the
yeah the um he'll be doing the majority
majority
okay i'm gonna close
the itl um passed it was uh 24 to
nothing and i'm going to close the
executive
i mean i'm sorry 21 nothing why'd i do
24. i must have counted myself three
times
21 nothing
yeah and i'm going to close the
executive on um 32.
okay yeah let me see yeah we
okay we're moving along we got looks
like three more but i
you'll check my numbers here cause
yeah okay i'm just three there was a
couple of them i gotta find
okay we all set
are we ready we're going to be going to
i'm sorry to i'm sorry to interrupt this
stacy you coming right back
all right tell you what why don't we um
yeah take a uh five-minute uh break
okay
uh we'll come no to do we'll come back
in here at 12 30.
so you can make bathroom breaks or
whatever 12 30.
okay
okay now
give me give me what we're doing in
order
for the committee um
i can move forward
or i can break for lunch whatever i'll
take you know
what do people want i mean i know some
people representative lundgren says he's
starving
okay so
i mean if you want to eat do you want to
what is the majority i mean anyone here
that have to go eat right now or no
let's get it or do we move forward
get it done okay
all right we'll go we're moving then
huh
[Music]
dave you're going to grab something over
there
i'll move forward i mean out of respect
for anyone else i'm a marine i could go
all day and not eat
take the hill and then eat after i take
i didn't have a chance to make anything
yesterday
it tastes like chicken okay so we're
going we're going 13 53 10 50. 12 48.
i've heard of that
i got till tomorrow morning at six
my friends on the democrats i don't know
i was actually in the oval office with
president obama
okay with my son who used to fly around
he was avionics electronics mechanic on
his president obama's helicopters he was
bush and then would you rather than
obama
and everyone else went in to take a
picture i was with my son
and what happened was i was in there for
about 10 minutes talking to president
obama on new hampshire he kept me there
to talk about new hampshire so i have
nothing against you know any clinton any
democrat
i thought president obama had a great
personality and
we just disagreed on policy
so i have a picture hanging in my house
of me in the oval office with president
obama
i'm gonna
i'm gonna open up the executive session
on 1353 and representative moffat you
had a uh
motion to make famous chair i would like
to move interim study on this measure
really
okay we have a motion on uh interim
study is there a second
yeah you can second if he wants go for
it
that's 1353.
in the new hampshire
home
okay
so
so that was moffat what's that
oh yeah we went on a field trip there
when i was on this committee and linda
and i we picked out a room for you right
next to the latrine
that's right
yeah who did the second
uh the branch okay
yes we did do a field trip matter of
fact i would have done it with this
committee but what i ended up doing was
a um zoom meeting and i brought in the
va and we brought in everyone so
you know they everyone that knew would
understand and know what process is to
help their constituents you know from
this committee
but anyways um i have a um an interim
study motion by representative moffat
second by uh representative branch
and would you like to speak to your
motion uh
representative thank you mr briefly uh i
i think many of us were uh conflicted by
the testimony that day there were some
very strong compelling arguments to
recognize the long service of this
gentleman
but also there was not just one but
several
individuals highly i think highly
regarded individuals who
did not support this
so i i think there's a need to reconcile
these two different uh perspectives on
so therefore i recommended interim study
thank you anyone else
want to speak
okay i
represent marshmallow
um i i agree with uh representative
moffett um
when i originally started the bill i was
in favor of it i read the resume that
mr conway had provided and that seemed
impressive
and then when i heard some testimony
about
possible hostile work environment
that really concerned me
so um i would agree interested
all right
i sponsored this bill on behalf of
executive council joe kenny asked me to
send it
i've worked with barry conway for many
many years
and i thought barry was utmost
professional
matter of fact i was the bad guy
who stated when he was leaving to make
sure that a veteran
was put in the spot
in that position and not somebody that
never served because i'm a true believer
in on ptsd tbi and other issues
veterans communicate with other veterans
for a veteran with ptsd or tb to go to a
ptsd to go to a civilian psychiatrist
that has no knowledge whatsoever on the
veteran community or going to combat
it's kind of tough you know talking to
somebody like that they really don't
understand so
i was kind of shocked there on the um
testimony and i think representative
conroy
connor
barry has a
not representative but barry has a
a suit against uh
you know on the way they treated him and
what was said here because
for the many years i've been on this
committee and been a chair before in a
vice chair before i've never heard of
any of it
never and i was in and out of the
veterans home barry done a lot for that
veterans home
matter of fact uh if anything the
numbers were kept up right now we're
about 100 and 203 in there when we have
bed space for 200.
okay and i never heard no complaints or
anything about shot or workers or this
or that you know and reasons why they
couldn't
you know versus i always heard why you
could
so i'll support the interim study
because i know the votes aren't there to
pass this here
and i feel bad uh you know on this here
and i think barry should go after them
because what was said in this committee
i thought was very unprofessional
okay because there was no nothing logged
in no they didn't bring anything it was
all hearsay or what they thought
uh you know or what one person said and
like i said i
when the commandant made that comment
there
i was thinking to myself geez i'm the
one that said the barry don't make sure
you get a veteran
you know uh to take over it's just my
mentality as an old retired marine there
so
um momentum study may be the right thing
to do since i don't want to see it itld
it keeps it alive and then of course
it's going to have to come back next
year if somebody's willing to step up
and do this for barry
but in my opinion
barry is a very honorable guy
the national
committeeman for the state of new
hampshire
assad major paul chevalier if anyone
knows him sent me a message was in
support
you know barry he's worked with barry
for many years he was a committeeman for
the bfw for many years
so that's why i was kind of shocked on
what went on but i'll support the
interim study
and i'll leave it at that
anyone else yes
uh thank you uh thank you mr chairman
most of the time naming bills come to
the public works and highways committee
and we've learned over the years to be
very cautious when there's controversy
and not move a bill forward if that
makes anyone feel better to the point
where if we're going to name a thing in
a town
we before we move the bill forward we
will get a physical letter from the town
saying that they approve of it so uh in
this case it sounds like there was
controversy so
probably the best action to take is is
interim study
if that makes anyone feel better about
putting it off right without a doubt i
agree and i've had my name on many
bridges naming after veterans that's who
i believe should be named after those
veterans that died in that community
fighting for freedom just my opinion
okay
see anything else
seeing that there's no uh other
information i'm gonna ask the clerk to
take a roll call vote on a house bill
interim study
okay
um
yes on interim study okay representative
lundgren yeah representative katz chorus
yeah representative rollins yes
representative delemus yes
representative notter yes representative
foster yes representative
yes representative harley yes
representative levitt right
representative massimila yes
representative piedra yes
representative querrey
yes
uh representative jack yes
representative oregon yes representative
okay without any objection we'll put
this on the consent calendar
okay you can send calendar
and mike moffat will do the um blurb on
that
uh let me just make my note here
1353 where i
consent this can go to representative
okay
i'm going to close the executive session
on hsb 1353
and we're going to move to house bill
and i think representative massa miller
told me she had a motion
thank you mr chair um i rep i recommend
interim study
is there a second
okay and uh representative we have a
motion on the floor interim study
uh by representative massa miller second
by representative shea
and uh would you want to speak to your
motion sure
um
the sponsor came forth and presented you
know information about armistice day and
so on and so forth and when i was a
child veterans day was called armistice
day and um just considering
that with maybe a little bit more
tweaking and stuff the bill would be
more amenable to various organizations
so i'm
recommending entrance study
okay
representative
i just want to encourage my colleagues
and the majority of the committee to to
um to vote for interim study i think
there is a way to to remedy this
possibly without um without it viewing
as if we're taking away from veterans on
such an important day there might be a
way to make it so that the state of new
hampshire also has official proclamation
for veterans day and also can recognize
a uh the more you know the holiday
that's celebrated throughout the
commonwealth because both are very
honorable things that you know we do
internationally and nationally so i
think there's a way to really think this
through so
um i don't think the current language is
uh you know does any justice um properly
to either veterans day or armistice day
so i think with some tweaks we can maybe
reach some consensus with the veterans
community and other stakeholders
okay
you know i've known representative
shirtless for a long time very honorable
guy
and um
i'll tell you uh veterans day is a day
to remember those that have served
you know an act you know act of reserve
or in the past or whatever
um
memorial day is the day that we
celebrate for those that have made the
ultimate sacrifice and this was a tough
one here you know because the more and
more i think of november 11th at 11
o'clock
you know whether it be called armistice
day one time remembrance day
um i just think veterans day should
continue now this does not mean that
representative shirtless or anyone else
could not go to the governor
and ask for a proclamation
you know uh identify in remembrance day
for their districts you can do that
so you know it doesn't have to be um
muddy in the water with the ac you know
the people that uh survive you know live
and served in you know veterans day
versus memorial day so i think it's the
right decision to interim study it and
i'll definitely be supporting it
matter of fact i'm gonna
put my
thing changed there i was gonna oppose
it because i part of me was on the fence
on it but
so i'm supporting
okay is there anything else anyone else
want to add anything to it and uh
without okay so without that uh nobody
else i am going to ask the clerk to take
a vote on house bill 1050 on interim
study
yes to interim study representative
lundgren yes representative kat zakoros
yes representative
rollins yeah
representative delanes yes
representative notter yes
representative foster
representative
yes representative harley
representative leavitt
representative massimilis yes
representative piedra yes
representative
yes
check yes
gallagher
yes
representative
representative lebranch yes
representative lawton
yes
yes and representative
yes okay that's 21. 21 to nothing
without objection anyone um on a consent
calendar
i'm going to close hb 1050
give us a second and we'll catch up
21-0
consent
and representative massa miller will do
okay
okay we're going to move over to hp
1284. i'm going to open up the executive
session on hb 1284
mr chair what's that uh did you get a
copy of the amendment that we're
proposing
on the amendment on what on 1284
what
i don't have a copy
what's that
okay but right now the motion i
understand his amendment the motion is
itl
it's an amendment yes you can't put a
okay
um
well i can't i'm sorry i can't hear you
with these mess i'm sorry i just want to
let you know that democrats got a copy
um when we caucus so it just needs to be
distributed to the republicans i will i
believe okay
it came in with someone i didn't
recognize and they said they were going
to give it to representative
that was that's all i know about it
i gave it to you you gave it to me so
it's got to be here somewhere there
and can't be
sprung away if you've gotten up and
walked off i tell you what i'll do
out of respect
i'll pull my motion back on the itl and
we'll go right into the amendment
thank you and we'll take it thank you
mister you'll take a look at it
we have our copies and the rest have
passed on
i should have
been told about it about brought it
forward but like i knew the branch is
what he was putting forward
that was my fault i apologize that's
right i'll blame you
i know you will
i think i think representative lundgren
you know
i have a thing dave is from londonderry
okay what we do we have an ought to pass
on an amendment wait let me get the
emotion where who's doing the motion
i make a motion uh to approve amendment
1280 hb 1284
to amend the title of the bill and
replace it
do you want to hear
should i should i continue and
okay
you want to speak to your amendment
yes this amendment uh simply uh changes
the original proposal from creating a
committee to creating a commission
so there would be a mix of
legislators and individuals from the
public to investigate costs
to new hampshire taxpayers associated
with deportation of individuals
from new hampshire and just very briefly
as we talked about
earlier when non-citizens who have
children who are american citizens are
held in detention or deported the costs
to new hampshire citizens is unknown
a commission would be charged with
collecting data and informing us about
the costs
of those
actions so we heard from case studies
about these costs but putting together a
group that would focus on collating this
information
okay anyone else before i speak
representative shares
yeah um so i'm looking at the uh
the legislative members so
section four i believe that's where it
lays out what the exact um you know what
the commission will be studying it's
still it says the commission shall
the effects of deportion of deportation
of primary earners on family members who
are united states citizens so
that correction that was from the last
um from the last the original underlying
bill still wasn't changed and it's still
um not addressing what the prime sponsor
wants the study or the commission to
address which is it's i keep hearing you
know what's the effects on the cost to
taxpayers it's looking specifically at
the effects to the families so i'm very
much confused now this amendment was
brought forward to kind of remedy those
concerns but not even the simple
grammatical change to make it
grammatically correct was made so um i
appreciate the um you know addressing a
number of the concerns that the majority
of the committee brought up but even
still it seems like only half of them
were considered and the uh the exact um
you know the exact uh scope
of this commission is so broad uh you
know i would want to know the fiscal
note too right how much how much
resource is this commission gonna need
to
study the deport you know such a complex
issue um
so for that reason i'm going to have to
oppose the amendment and the underlying
bill um
you know i did talk to the prime sponsor
yesterday and today and i told her that
we'd give this more than a fair chance
and the amendment that i expect to be
coming late that would give it more than
a fair chance and a you know an
opportunity i'm a pretty open-minded guy
but still you know the concerns
addressed uh brought up by the majority
still are not
fully addressed
if i may just speak to you can for a
moment um go ahead no and i appreciate
and i i appreciated your questions uh
originally at the hearing i thought they
were
they were good ones um
um and in terms of i know you had
concerns for example about data
collection like
you know are you initiating a large
research study here
what we know is that many organizations
non-governmental organizations
throughout the state collect a lot of
information about this so this group by
studying the effects
would be able to go to those
organizations collect that kind of data
now by effects there is a
series of effects right so for example a
case study was introduced where with the
ayala family where
um
the the kids uh lose their dad for a
year to an
to deportation
procedures and they incur
mental health problems school-related
problems which relate which lead to ieps
individual education plans which in turn
lead to special education costs that the
taxpayers of the state of new hampshire
must incur so when you say
facts
you have to not just say money
ultimately we want to know what the
costs are but you have to look at
what what effects does this have on
individuals which then leads to
costs
real costs to the taxpayer
good good yeah no i certainly i
certainly understand that but typically
commissions have a number of you know
for example the um
uh the uh what's it called the
commission that we established in house
bill um 1441 right there was there was
about eight points that the commission
would address um effects is just a very
you know it's very broad like i said i i
think that you know this really you know
is going to be
one thing is i don't even think we'd be
statutorily uh establishing that they
can collect that information from from
private organizations too right we've
just said the effect so it seems like
we'd have to use any state information
that we have which we know we lack
thereof to
for the commission to look at and then
it doesn't even say that they'll compile
it i don't even
i haven't had a moment to read but it
doesn't even say it'll compile it into a
report commission shall okay any
recommendations for proposed legislative
okay so they'll
put forward recommendations but i don't
even see that it says oh shall report
okay so that would be a report my
apologies on that but even still um
you know the prime sponsor said at
length multiple times um this is to
study the costs the cost the cost of the
public and this doesn't in any way in
any demonstrable way say that that's
what this commission will be studying it
just says the effects and i'm you know
the way i read it says the commission
shall you know
the word study should be there shall
study the effects of deportation of
primary earners on families who are
united states citizens it seems like
we're just studying the effect on the
family we're not studying any of the
public costs and with that i mean you
know it seems like the intent even of
the amendment and the underlying bill is
not in conjunction with what the prime
sponsor intended and um you know i know
she's tried a few years at this and i
would hope that after hearing the
recommendations and seeing the majority
reports um and the kinds of things that
she would make the proper remedies to um
to address that and you know i know
she'll probably run for re-election
again and she's in a pretty safe
district and she'll probably get
re-elected again so she'll have ample
opportunity to uh to take another stab
at this next time
okay
represent mars miller
um just in response to representative
deshay when we were talking about house
bill 1411 and about removing the part
that had to do with reporting on federal
refugee locations somebody from your
side did mention the fact that the
reason why it should be included is
because it will give us data as far as
schools and monies and things like that
so
this
this bill would help to supplement
that piece
of it
if i may mr chairman
uh i mean i think uh whoever said on
this side i don't think it was myself
but i think they were mistaken because
the only data we'd collect would be the
number of refugees that we just know the
number i don't even know if we know
where they were relocated to right i'm
not sure it's it would be at the
discretion of the federal government to
um to report that so i think um you know
to each their own i think there's
private there's a lot of private
information that can be compiled by
other ngos and i think it's honorable
stuff that they would do to compile that
information it just doesn't seem like
this commission will be able to serve
the intent of what the prime sponsor
wanted and i think that's the biggest
takeaway at least from my perspective
okay my representative moffat
thank you mr chair
i'm actually inclined to look uh
favorably at this amendment
because
if the if the major thrust of it is to
change from a committee to a commission
i
i had
always had reservations about it being a
strictly legislative commission a
committee
i think a commission uh is better
and i i think that in a sense this may
be a one vote
ultimately a one-vote margin either way
on on this
i would rather vote for the better bill
[Music]
at the end of the day than for a lesser
bill
so again if you're tracking what i'm
what i'm trying to say and this is from
experience from other committees
i think that this amendment improves
the bill
so whether or not i would vote vote for
the otp in the end i i'm not saying at
this point but i think i'm inclined to
vote for anything that gives us a better
bill to ultimately consider if if you're
tracking me on that
thank you uh
just uh to add to this this bill's been
here geez how many times
the bottom line is
the federal government is responsible
for immigration
how school problems
private information you can't get it
social problems psychiatry doctor dr
hippa protected how you can't get the
information
healthcare hipaa protected you're not
going to get that information
uh federal taxes on individuals once
again protected information you're not
going to get it
this commission is feel
good
to the people
but cannot do nothing it's a waste
in my opinion it's a waste because we
have no power on immigration if we want
to know how much money is being spent
all you got to do is check with uh your
local on how many yes i don't even know
they give you the nominee numbers
they're illegal on the children if
whether they can give you that number
okay in the school systems i don't know
if that's even we can even get that
um
so yoga you want to pass something that
does no weight whatsoever but to people
in the community you give them false
hope that's what you give them with this
here because there's not a damn thing
you can do as legislators in new
hampshire
and believe me i tried it in my district
a family they got kicked out the father
had to leave
but the the kids were all you know they
were american citizens
okay but then they have to go back to
the proper procedure on sponsoring him
to bring him back
okay that's the law there are laws that
will land here but the president today
does not want to comply with those laws
they're saying we want to fix
immigration but they're not doing
nothing democrats were in charge
republicans were in charge nobody
changed immigration laws
so the laws are there for a reason and
we want to subside and move aside the
laws and say let's try to pick something
we know damn well
we have no control over sounds good wow
look at us we're proud we're going to do
something here for the
people there that are the breadwinners
that have moved out of the state but
what are you going to do can somebody
show me or tell me
what you can do for that person when
it's a federal law and there's no state
law that covers it can somebody help me
out here and show me that why i should
change my mind
anyone in the room here
there's the bridge
not good look mr branch
i think everybody in this room can agree
that immigration is a federal issue
i believe that this bill does not
directly tackle that but it's it's doing
its part in
let us study how much our state is
losing in revenue and spending uh
on these children of people who are
being deported or families of people who
are being deported and let us tell our
congressional delegation that
we're spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars uh i i would assume if these
people are deported we're losing this
can i stop you for a second here you're
not answering my question
how can you find this information that
is illegal to get
that we have no power unless you have
subpoena power how are you going to get
the data
you answer my question please
tell me on this why i should support the
commission
to that i guess i would say it's more
about the raw data not the personal
information
there is
there is information may i respond yeah
there is information that's collected by
these organizations across the state
american friends religious organizations
um
uh colleges and universities are doing
research studies in these areas
so the commission's job would be to
reach out to those groups not to launch
their own research studies and i think
when representative deshay asked those
questions they were good ones uh at the
original
hearing how would you do that
precisely
that's how they would have to do it they
wouldn't launch their own
research studies they would have to
collect data from these groups on the
ground that are collecting this data so
that we can know
what is the effect
on these actions on our taxpayers so
as representative lebranch said so we
can
report to our congressional leaders
what these problems are that are
affecting us right here in new hampshire
so that would be my response all right
and i'm going to continue to go on this
here because you have congressional
leaders have been there six twelve years
four you know four six years what have
they done on this
what have they done for the nothing
so we're gonna do and spend money on
travel and everything else on
legislators and get data
that you can pick up the phone and call
your your state senator i mean your u.s
senate and your congress right now and
say hey we got a problem uh you know we
got people that are being
sent out here they know that she was the
governor
hassan was the governor
you know i mean maybe it's time to start
replacing people whether it be
republican or democrats are not doing
their jobs
you know what i'm saying but but you
want to do this here commission
and give the people
false hope
because there's not a damn thing we can
do it's a federal issue it's a
constitutional issue so any of my
republicans support something like this
here you go it's a constitutional issue
what are we going to do
what can we what can we prove nothing um
mr chair
my question is when you say give them
false hope who you say who's that
talking to people that their
breadwinners have been um you know uh
deported
in the american citizens what they call
what there's a name for it uh when they
come in and they have children they come
in pregnant have kids here or they had
anchor babies because you know i mean
that hasn't been settled in the courts
yet in the supreme court but i'm saying
those people are thinking new hampshire
legislators are doing the best damn
thing for me they're looking out for me
they're going to fix it now because
they're looking up at the data when
really if you wake up and smell the
coffee it's not a damn thing we can do
nothing and we spent all this money
i don't think they're thinking that that
this is going to remedy their situation
i just think that with more data and how
it affects the community they live in
because they do bring in revenue and how
it's going to affect their families i
think that's what we're looking for well
there's other areas they bring in they
bring a lot bringing crime they're
bringing revenue i mean it's a
two-three-way street i mean you got
people being killed around the country
with duis by people that aren't licensed
or illegals from other countries so
there's a lot of stuff they bring in
but most good many of them are working
people hard-working people
you know what i mean but you have some
that are you know bringing in crime but
the bottom line is
this does this no good because it's a
food so well we're going to know okay we
spent 300
or we on we spent millions of dollars in
education we already know that we
already know manchester schools all you
got to do is call the school system and
they'll tell you how much money they're
paying for 62 or 65 foreign teachers you
know for foreign languages yes sir
thank you mr
i think we're getting into discussing
the totality of the bill and as i said
earlier for me the immediate question is
does the amendment is the amendment
better than the original bill and as
i've already said i think i think a
commission is better than the committee
for reasons numerous reasons so for me
the immediate question
for me is is is the amendment better
than the original i think it is so i'm
inclined to vote for the amendment and
then and then we could have a
a fuller discussion on the bill and its
totality that that's where i i'm at
point of order mr chairman would a
motion over to your right is emotion in
order right now
um yeah on the bill yeah well i'd like
well there's can i move the question
can i can i move the question
no i can't move the question i move the
question no i
don't read mason's manual yeah you can't
move them on the floor you can
uh of the house but in the committee you
can't move the question okay thank you
and i have mason's manuals here if you
want i trust you mr chairman i just was
checking okay uh anyone else
representative horrigan um
of course a lot has gone by since that
but one of the arguments you made was
that
we couldn't get this information without
subpoena power by um i believe actually
i know certainly
the house has does have subpoena power
and i think we both remember when that
rule was passed about 10 years ago so
we actually the commission probably
would have subpoena power although it's
fairly cumbersome because on the house
side you have to go through rules
and then wait for a session day and then
to get majority of the house to vote for
the subpoena but we do in fact have
subpoena this commission could have
subpoena power if it
you but been here 15 years and never
seen it once we tried it a few years
back when we when we went after a judge
uh yeah to impeach a judge yes and we we
couldn't get it yeah we went after it on
a redress uh on a marital master and we
couldn't get it so this is why i'm
trying to say this is feel good
commission yeah and i think we're making
a mistake on supporting it and just best
off it
and then you all have the power to call
your senators until you send they get
off a butt both of them
and you know and it just isn't democrats
so don't get me wrong it's republicans
and democrats
that aren't uh have been fixing this for
years the federal law is here for a
reason
okay
without any i'm going to ask uh my
collection says nothing else here to uh
take a roll call vote on
yes on amendment
h
okay
complete
i on the otp
okay
foster
yes
representative
representative lawton yes representative
yes
no
okay
and i have a motion
even though you have not
as as amended of course well don't make
a difference yet until we itl goes so
motion motion
itl
on the bill on the bill
okay yeah because we don't necessarily
have to go to an author pass and go
right to an itl
okay
no i just itl itl its the motion there's
no itl with an amendment
the minority position right what what
this does here this helps the uh
minority they can take that amendment
and put it in the count and then on a uh
for a floor amendment you know if we do
an itl on the uh the bill
okay
a
second okay
hp 1284.
and i am going to
say
moffat
wait no we're not voting yet is anyone
yeah not yet
um we have a motion on the floor itl um
by me and then second by brody is there
anyone in here that wants to speak on
this itl
uh
i will agree with what i believe a
member on the other side will say that
this bill needs a lot of work even just
as written uh it needs a lot of work
just grammatically and procedurally
and for that i would support the itl
motion
representative moffitt
famous your uh point of order i'm trying
to understand so i
we just
approved the amendment yes
and now we're and now we've got a motion
there for not to pass on the bill
so so this is not we're not
voting on otp as amended we're voting on
itl
okay so my my comment on that is uh as i
try to explain a couple of times i i
think the amendment makes the bill
better and i always want to vote on
whatever moves forward if it moves
forward i want the best bill to move
forward
and i think that a better bill is a
commission as opposed to a committee
which is why i supported the amendment
that said
uh if if we're now looking at a itl
motion
on the bill itself
i would support that because i don't
think that the as has been said from
both sides there's there's work that
needs to be done on this so
if we're looking at an itl motion it
sounds like we are i would support itl
of of the of the measure
one thing one thing you'll learn uh with
experience on being up here there and
i'm sure representative hogan knows you
never take a bad bill and try to make it
a better bill you end up making worse
and you don't uh dodge your eyes and
crush your t's
you know i mean like i said it's one of
those things that sound good but
this here
is there's a lot of work here especially
with the federal you need to get federal
law changed
you know i mean before you can move
forward because otherwise you're voting
there going against the constitution we
all take the oath and the constitution
the support and defend
that's why that um
your um
amendment sounds good but it still goes
against the constitution
thank you
uh yes
i just want to thank the uh the the
minority uh minority of the committee
for uh putting this forward and trying
to address our concerns it's a um it's
an honorable olive branch but still i
think the the core for me is still the
scope
of this study and i keep hearing
taxpayers we're going to see how it
affects taxpayers this commission as
established in statutory law would not
be studying that it would be studying
the effects of deportation of primary
earners on family members who are in the
united states there's nothing this
commission you know and it's a study
that we're voting to itl but let's say
theoretically somehow you guys find some
votes to make it so then you get to the
ought to pass as amended motion on the
floor and if this went into law
the the scope of the commission is still
on the effects of the family members who
are united states citizens
so it's not on the taxpayer
ramifications and i'm not sure if i'm
you know i've never been a part of a
commission but i'm not sure if a
commission can deviate away from its
originally statutorily uh its statutory
responsibilities right so with that i
mean what the what the minority party
wants this now you know
the commission to do
i this bill doesn't have the commission
do that and you know that's why i'm
going to be voting against the bill
um i voted for the amendment because i
thought i appreciated the attempt at
trying to improve something and
addressing my concerns but still um
you know that section four needs to be
completely overhauled right it's just
too too vague
scope's too large and what is being
addressed is not what the bill sponsor a
number of folks in the minority have
mentioned what they actually want to
have addressed thank you
thank you anyone else
representative hogan um yes the term
primary earners however
those people who
are being deported were by definition
taxpayers because they were
even if
um
well even though we don't have a famous
donor state income tax there's still the
federal income tax which they would have
to pay and then we do if they're working
for
a private business there's also the
business enterprise tax which
effectively is an income tax paid just
paid for by the employer rather than by
the employee and of course they're
paying
taxes on electricity and other prepared
foods and other things like the
primary earners are by definition
taxpayers so at least it's a very bad
effect if you deport somebody
on people who are taxable some taxpayers
are being very severely uh affected by
this if you deport them and
thank you representative i'm a former
human resource manager when i get out of
the marine corps can you tell me when
they fill out the w-2 w-4 or the 1090 uh
these different forms that you fill out
trying to remember it's been a while
where does it show that you're illegal
and where does it show on your data and
how much money
you're gonna uh how would they be able
to get that information on this
commission
well that i um
well you can't get it from the w-2s w-4s
or 1099s because that doesn't check off
even whether the person is taxes that
was sent in i'm saying where does it say
that they're uh green card or they're
illegal
um i
haven't
that we'll get that information i mean i
want you to break it down and think
about what i'm trying to bring i mean
they do
i mean there is data out there on like
uh
what
what the uh
what the so-called primary earners are
doing and i'm sure in the private sector
if it doesn't exist that's something the
commission will find out i mean
certainly i
don't think that's going to be under
federal tax form so
thanks
mr mr chairman may i respond
uh yeah good yeah um i just i still you
know
we got to look at the grammar of the
language of the bill right and it says a
committee shall and you know forgets
word study but shall study the effects
because that's what's implied she'll
study the effects of deportation of
primary earners on
family members who are united states
citizens we're not studying the primary
earners we're not studying the people
who are deported
quite literally they're out of the
country because they were deported not
in america anymore i don't even know how
we could find them
we're studying on
family members who are united states
citizens that's what the study is about
that's it that's the only thing that
we're studying and what we're studying
in regards to them is how they were
affected by the deportation of primary
earners we're talking about taxpayers
taxpayers costs costs communities
communities
we're only going this the only the only
thing this study committee and you know
theoretical commission could study
according to the statutory law that we'd
establish you know that the general
court and if it was even signed by the
governor would be how does the
deportation of that primary earner which
isn't defined in the bill either what is
a primary earner could it be multiple
primary owners one primary primary
earner um
how does that affect the family members
and there's been a lot of legitimate
questions as to how do you collect that
information on the family members how do
you do that and the commission in no way
kind of establishes how it's going to
compile those things too because it
doesn't really
establish what exactly it's going to be
doing in section 4 of the amendment so
with that you know it's kind of what
we're talking about whether it's
constitutional it's kind of a move point
this bill doesn't do what it's intended
to do and a lot of people are kind of
misconstruing what its intent is
okay
in my opinion the bill's not ready for
prime time but uh what i'm gonna do out
of respect for the uh my friends on the
left here uh they're
uh
they requested a caucus so we're gonna
how much time
five minutes all right so we'll give
them ten minutes here for a quick caucus
there they want to caucus on this bill
okay
okay i'm going to open back up the
executive uh session on hb 1284. we have
a motion on the floor uh here uh for itl
and um
are we done conversating with us here
are we going to a vote i'd just like to
thank you mr chair for uh giving us the
caucus time no problem i appreciate it
thank you yeah if it was uh
representative hogan who requested that
he said no but you you know
no represent you know i'm only kidding
right
yes
you do know i'm only kidding
yes yes this time
little sense of yuma okay
all right we're gonna move on uh since
there's no other conversations on the
then i'm going to ask
the clerk to go to a vote itl
on house bill 1284. okay
thank you mr chair
representative moffitt
to itl
representative lundgren yes
representative katz chorus yes
representative rollins
representative delemus yes
representative knotter yes yes
representative foster
representative deshay yes
representative harley yes representative
levitt oh yeah representative
matthemilla no
representative piedra no
representative query no representative
representative horrigan no
representative gallagher
no
representative told
now
yes
uh representative lawton
no
and representative walker woods no
and representative
yays
okay will the minority be doing a uh a
report
okay represent uh well quits doing the
and i'll be doing the one on the
okay that's for welcome it's down there
and i'm going to close the i'm hearing
itl
was 13 to 8 and
shut down hbo
can we change who's going to write the
minority report yeah who's going to
write to uh representatives toll
told okay and said well that's fine yeah
thank you mm-hmm representative told us
doing the uh
minority
okay yeah what are we moving on today
yeah i have to research the federal law
give me one sec we'll move okay that's
hp 1284 that goes with that
now the ones that i couldn't find
um
let me just get a catch up here yeah you
go forward 12.84 wait but i'm looking
itl
uh
13 8
13 8 okay
so
me
and then told is doing the
minority
amendment
okay just give me a second we're still
catching up here does anyone actually
have
on your uh
on the amendment on the um hp 1284 what
was the vote on edmonton i've got the
amendment i just need this i just need
on that amendment on twelve eighty forty
four who's the boat fifteen to six
yeah fifteen to six here hero okay i get
it right there okay
um
no six is right 21.
okay
okay so now
consent concern let me see which one i'm
missing here
hb 1441
just i'm just trying to catch up here
you were i'm going to open up the
executive session on hcr 8
uh resolution affirming states rights
based on jeffersonian principles
and i'm going to ask representative
matt samuel and representative lundgren
and massimilia moved
okay representative you want to speak to
this this bill has been
short and sweet i like it anyone else
on
okay seeing none i am going to ask the
itl hcr8
yes to itl
representative lundgren yes
representative katzacorus yes
representative
rollins yes
representative delaney yes
representative notter
representative foster
yes
representative
representative harley yes representative
leavitt for the last
[Music]
yes
gallagher
representative
yes
representative lebranch
should be 20 to one nothing
without objection on the consent
calendar
okay um
so
hcr eight
um itl 21 nothing on the consent
calendar and i'm going to close the
executive session on hcr8 and i believe
that is our last one
i'm i'm going to ask you if you have um
majority or minority to get them turned
in
because i will not be around for a week
to sign them off if we want to get them
in the calendar
for next week
and
i want to thank you all there for the
last few days
that
we did that a while ago 1653 was um
first one yeah i know but i'm looking on
my list
you weren't here though
you didn't come in no she was
no 60 we
we
held the hearing in the morning on that
but we did an executive no we executed
after
um yeah it was about to pass 21-0
you were there
yeah you voted
thank you thank you thank you
i want to thank you all there especially
the ones that came in and uh wanted to
be part of the committee there we
appreciate your support
you